Hey dirty fucks.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by stamps.com
if you have a small business and you have to go to the post office,
you know what a pain in the deck that can be.
That shit ain't good for you.
That's stress.
That stress can be avoided if you stamps.com which you can do is they give you
your own digital scale.
You could print up all your shit on your own PC or computer,
Mac,
Mac or PC.
Either one works and you just put your own postage on it and then the post
office comes and they pick it up and that's it.
You don't have to do any of that waiting online shit.
You don't have to wait like so many ways.
Your stuff and then figure it all out.
You do it all from your house.
It's super easy and people that are operating small businesses like a,
if you buy any of the desk,
squad.tv tee shirts,
this is how Brian sends him.
Yeah,
so no other way to do it.
I mean,
if you have any,
like a small business or even if you're just like getting into something like an
online store like Etsy or something,
when you went sell like some art work or anything that you're,
you're shipping stuff out,
there's no reason to go to that post office nowadays.
Just some freak pitch and wants to sell panties.
Right.
But you know,
you don't want to go to the post office,
the dirty start weighing panties,
which you want to do is how many boys he sent panties to figure this shit out.
That's,
that could be a business man.
I guarantee you there's money in that because Duncan knew a girl who would wear
socks and stuff.
They would want her to get her feet stinky and then she would send them dirty
socks.
Statute wasn't or anything like dirty stench.
It had,
she had some sort of an unfortunate name,
but she called herself.
But that was like her thing.
Like she would,
she would,
uh,
get paid to wear underwear for like several days in a row.
She was the first person I ever knew actually did that.
Not yet.
And then I want you to,
did she fucking did it legit?
Like if they told her she had to wear socks for like three days,
she would wear socks for three days and she wouldn't let a guy do it.
Like,
no,
you can't wear my socks.
Like it has to be my stinky feet.
If there had to be like a tan stain,
at least maybe they do.
Maybe you could smell it and you're like,
there's no way a chick's feet smelled this fucking bad.
I'm not beating off to a dude stinky feet.
Got Damn.
It sounded like somebody wouldn't know that I'm cutting maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that is,
that does sound like someone who had no Dunkin a and that might be something too
that it might be.
If you want to keep an honest foot stinky socks business,
you gotta,
you gotta do the right thing.
That was going through a phase of his life,
I think often it was hanging out with that girl.
Well yes,
this is,
this is getting very personal.
If you go to stamps.com and click on,
there's a little microphone in the upper right hand corner and around the code
word j r e and you get this a sweet deal where they give you,
they give you a free digital
Gail,
they give you a 55 bucks and,
and postal coupons.
Um,
it's,
it's a sweet deal and uh,
you can,
you can save a lot of money
to up to 80% compared to a meter.
That's according to them.
I have done no research and that scale is pretty bad ass.
You just hook it up to your computer.
Don't use it for pot.
You fucks.
This is for selling,
sending shit through the mail.
And I would advise you to not send pop through the mail.
I think that's like really Dana.
That's super label.
Yeah.
Isn't that funny?
Like you can,
if you carry it in your ass,
it's less illegal than if you send it across state lines.
Like if you stuff a half a pound of weed up your ass,
they'll at least be impressed.
How put bound,
yeah.
Yeah.
But if you stuff,
you know
a teddy bear,
my ass,
my ass is broad capacity
only person I've ever seen that brags about how big their asses the inside of
the acids.
Dana D Armand.
Oh yeah.
Talking about a whole bigger butters because she fits cat toys up there.
Yeah.
It's weird like some of those gaping videos when you could see shadows on the
wall,
it's pretty bad.
There's no need for that gaping stuff.
That's the society gone wrong when they look back at us in the future.
The way we look at Rome and the vomitorium comes and all the doodling of the
young people that they're going to look at us and gaping going,
what the fuck they were into gay cause it's they,
they would,
they won't really represent what a small percentage of the population actually
and George,
those videos,
just the fact that they exist is,
it's evidence enough that we've gotten mad.
We've gone completely mad.
We're spitting inside girls assholes.
We're opening them up and spitting in there and that's,
that's a,
a genre in pornography.
It's not like a onetime thing like somebody went and then I lost my mind,
man.
I opened number button,
I spit in there.
I don't even know what the fuck I was doing.
Dude,
don't do that again.
I mean that's so disrespectful.
How do you think she feels?
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I got to stop smoking meth.
But instead,
no,
it's a fucking John Rhe there's like there's how many videos are there?
Okay.
I remember when like a long time ago I saw an important,
like my first time that somebody spitting on the crotch before paying ne using
it like a some spit lube.
I actually did it on Katie.
I
no guy wants that information out there spitting on her crotch.
She's fucking,
she got pissed off and then you should granted the bathroom and like washed her
and it didn't want to have sex.
That would totally not horny at all.
You fucked up well there.
Why?
I had a little chest cold so it might have something to do with,
oh,
how dare you know stamps.com codeword jre save yourself some way.
That's how you do a commercial bitch.
All right?
That's the only way I know.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by audible.com if you go to audible.com forward slash
Joe,
you can get one free audio book and 33 days of audible service.
If you've never used audible before,
it's a really fucking sweet service for looking for anything.
And people have said this to me,
like some guy said to me on Twitter,
he shouldn't,
uh,
advertise that people listen
to a audio books when,
uh,
when they're stuck in traffic because that's what we use.
Your podcast four,
that's like,
you're competing against yourself.
Like,
do you know any fucking people there are out there?
Do you know how many fucking people there are?
It's madness and water's going to go where it's supposed to go.
Okay?
It all gets the attention it deserves.
And if you want to read a fucking book on your transit,
you should not be listening to me.
If you,
if you decided,
you know,
I'm gonna use this time to educate myself.
Well,
I don't fit into that plan.
So I suggest if that's your meat,
then you do use audible instead of this podcast.
How about them apples?
I think audio books are some of the coolest things that people have ever been
invented.
If you're a commuter,
you know,
cause it makes flying on a plane or in which is,
the same thing as podcasts.
Podcasts too.
And in fact,
a lot of podcasts,
uh,
one that I listened to a lot,
Dan Carlin's hardcore history,
you can get that on audible.
You can also get over 100,000 different books.
I mean,
just an amazing collection of books,
uh,
as well as shows,
old radio shit podcast,
standup comedy specials,
uh,
just to the opiod Anthony show.
It's great.
It's beautiful service.
And,
uh,
like I said,
if you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you can try audible free for 30 days and you can get one free audio book.
You know what's cool about it is,
is like if you listen to a lot of podcasts that you need and instead just start
listening to audio books.
Uh,
when you're done listening to an audio book,
you can say,
I just read a book.
You know what I mean?
Like where when you listen to a podcast,
listen to podcast not to,
so I have a radio.
I told you I'm a fucking in love with that Dan Carlin's hardcore history
podcast.
And even though you can't say you read a book after you get through one of
those,
it's way better than reading a book.
It's super educational.
We can't quantify it like you kind of book.
But that,
that podcast is not just inspiration,
but that guy is a master storyteller.
So these fucking fascinating stories,
man.
It's really good stuff.
That is awesome.
And to think about him is that he's not a,
he always say,
oh,
I'm not really a historian.
He's way better than any historian because he,
I can actually tell a story and he has no dog in the game.
He's there to try to discern the facts as clear as possible.
He gives several different accounts of each situation is it's been deciphered
what people agree on,
what,
you know,
as far as like numbers and how many killed and shit like that would really,
really,
really interesting stuff,
man.
Um,
audible.com go check it out.
You can get Dan Carlin's hardcore history.
Do you any of any of your books do you have on audible yet?
You know,
I didn't know.
It pisses me off too sexy.
Your voice too sexy.
Cool.
Is the old or the female population offered to turn lesbian since they cannot
possibly be satisfied by another man?
Old Man would be very sad.
I can't do that.
Or they can have men agreed to only make love to them while they're wearing
headphones listening to your voice.
That's right.
So it's,
well,
we need to get you to do one of those,
cause that would be bad ass.
You know,
maybe you can just do it.
I mean,
um,
didn't Scottsville Sigler do that then?
Isn't that how we,
uh,
started out,
was it Scott Sigler who,
uh,
had all the podcasts that he released with all of his books?
The author.
Yeah.
I mean that guy became really popular by just releasing his,
uh,
his books and pop cap in podcast form Tony Solon.
Yeah.
He did it on a song.
He's a go getter dude.
You know,
it just was unhappy with the,
the publishing world.
Like you're trying to deal with people,
you know,
maybe had a bad experience.
Right.
You can easily have a bad experience.
Just the wrong publisher,
the wrong people,
the wrong people with the wrong ideas of where you should go.
Yeah.
Um,
anyway,
go check it out.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com if you haven't been to on it
lately.
We add a lot of shit on it.
Basically started off selling nutritional supplements like mostly a nootropics
like Alpha brain and shroom tech sport,
which is an endurance enhancing supplement made out of a court accepts mushroom.
It's a real trippy thing.
They actually grow these mushrooms on fucking caterpillars.
It's very strange stuff.
Yeah,
they apparently,
the story is the lore is that high altitude hurting populations,
they noticed that their cows,
their cattle were more active when they're eating this mushroom.
So they tried to figure out how to grow it and how to do it in process it in a
commercial way and it's also related to them.
That mushroom that fucks with ants,
it turns them into zombies that that is one of the weirdest like parasite
relationships in the animal world.
How does it work?
What does the court accepts is different strain of cordyceps.
Mushroom gets inside of the ant,
affects the aunt and when the other ants know it's infected,
they take him way out of town.
Like they're like,
we got to get him the fuck out of here because they know he becomes a bomb so
they,
they have to take him out of town and then when they leave him there he explodes
and sends mushroom spores into the air,
which I liked some invaders of the body snatchers type shit.
It just lands on other ants,
gets into them and fax them,
takes them over and then the same thing,
they explode and become mushroom bombs.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
What though?
Fuck Dude.
By the way,
have you seen this part of your,
on its website?
What is it is all about lucid dreaming.
It's one of the most amazing website I've ever that you just scroll down and
it's all about lucid dreaming and there's like,
like these cool visuals that pop up.
And then there's one point where like the whole space like starts spinning
around.
Listen man,
lucid dreaming.
I've had lucid dream experiences before but I've never had them as strong as
I've had them before.
Taking Alpha brain.
That's a fact is,
and I think it's not just Alpha brain.
I think if you,
you know,
you want to try it.
I believe Coleen is one of the big ones responsible for it.
A lot of people have a report similar,
similar
results and a,
I think that when you take things like that are psychoactive like that,
like,
um,
nootropics at night,
uh,
I think it has a pretty profound effect on your dream state.
Lot of people have reported it.
I've always said that it's one of the most,
um,
one of the best pieces of evidence to the,
the efficacy of Alpha brain is what the fuck it does to your dreams.
It's hard to tell whether or not something's giving you an edge.
Like whether your brain is performing faster or slower cause it's all so
subjective.
It varies with how much sleep you've had or how annoyed you are at various was
so,
so much.
But what Alpha brain provides is all the nutrients,
all the building blocks for human truth.
What are you writing?
Fuckhead dreams,
man,
I was totally fucking my because are you putting that up online?
Fucked my cousin.
So you,
what you're doing is you're putting in a fake comment while we're doing a show.
You're putting on a fake comment,
which you shouldn't do anyway.
This website,
whoever made this website,
Joe,
you need to make,
have him make your website because this is like breakthrough website
development.
Really.
This is amazing.
This is fun.
What's so amazing?
It's you can draw pictures.
Did you just see that thing?
I was scrolling through that.
So cool.
Oh
yeah.
It's pretty interesting.
You draw a deck
on,
good check out there.
We also did a little circle.
That's a fucking monster of a circumcision scar sign that someone's trying to
stab your Dick.
One hair.
Okay,
stop.
Uh,
we also have a kettle bells battle ropes,
all sorts of a strength of fitness equipment that we sell in there.
Now,
if you use a codename Rogan and you'll save 10% off any and all supplements,
uh,
and so that's it.
You Fox,
did you see that Yahoo knew was brought up,
uh,
on Nick today?
No.
What did they say they were,
they did that,
these articles about Duane Ludwig and he would say,
now he,
uh,
he reviews the fight tapes a not throw out then he's most Swedes.
And then human study left a review of the fight tapes when he's,
when he's sticking out of her brain.
And they were saying basically how he,
he feels like each time he,
each state of consciousness that you've reviewed the fights taping gives him a
little bit differently for,
from the one before.
And of course Yahoo News being,
you know,
Sini Carla and whatever.
They're like,
yeah it is.
But all dope dod they say makes you smarter and more acute.
Ya whatever.
That's very funny in your voice.
That's shitty paraphrase with your accent.
It's like she's crying.
It trains conversation.
Yeah.
You know,
things like Alpha brain of course.
Anything that claims to make you smarter.
It sounds stupid.
I mean ironically,
but there's absolutely been proven.
There's certain nutrients that enhance the way your brain functions.
I've tried a bunch of different ones.
Um,
I can't say enough.
I don't give a fuck if you buy this.
This is my,
my best way to try to describe anything that we sell it on it.
It's all shit I buy.
It's all shit
I would buy.
It's all shit that I endorsed because I've tried and I've had a positive benefit
from it.
All the nootropics,
the,
the fitness supplements,
all the food like hemp force protein powder,
it's all shit that I would use.
It's all great stuff.
We try to give you the best shit we can find and at reasonable prices.
And again,
if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you save 10% off any supplements and you could fly bitch.
Yeah,
I got to check into this lucid dream,
um,
solve problems while we're starting to call
down with how to be done,
had to be done.
There was not enough cults out there.
They're making any sense it can be done correctly,
folks.
OK.
Dot Com code name,
Rogan and go fuck yourself.
All right.
Daniela [inaudible] is here and not just the name,
the way it rolls off the tongue.
It makes her stimulating conversation there.
One of the three people in the United States who can actually turn out and say
time.
Definitely time please my friend.
It's easy.
I'm a professional talker.
Hit.
It's on the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Dan Yeley.
Bolelli mom,
man,
we'll be back.
Hey,
there we go.
The um,
that the,
does that sound of the Italian language man,
the Italians really figured out how to make shit sound good.
Like to do was say in it.
Like,
I was at Disneyland today and there's a couple that was talking next to us that
was like clearly Italian [inaudible] another Da da.
Like it's uh,
like they're singing a little song.
Like it sounds good.
Oh,
it's awesome.
Because when I think about it is like I've been here 20 years and they still
speak like a fob,
but because it's Italian fall,
but then it's like,
Ooh,
resulted in European,
it's cool.
[inaudible] the doors open for me.
Whereas if I was bull Gary on or some shit,
I would be,
we would be not trusting you and your problem.
Learn how to speak English right.
Already.
You sound like
beautiful class assist or something.
Some dude from a bygone time when men were elegant.
Okay.
And the number of times that I see,
I say sensing in the classroom when I realized my students are just looking at
each other.
What did you say?
Like I did this for ever.
Nobody ever told the artist I worked with.
Always use the word.
Um,
you know when I say sovereignty,
silver Ragaini team.
Oh No,
it was really,
I never heard they tie all these studies a plus B so her regulate the sound
about right.
So I used it over and over again.
Nobody ever said anything.
Right.
So clearly nobody understood sheet of what I was saying.
And what they gelled was like,
are you trying to say solver?
So for Raggedy,
yes.
I was saying
I smoking vape with mine.
Interesting.
When you're learning a language you need never in you,
you've never said words that are like fairly common room.
I sovereignty like I have a few,
there's a few that occasionally like I don't,
I can't think of any off the cuff but I know there's some where I've only read
them,
I've never said them.
And then when someone says him I'm like,
which one is that?
Is that the silent Gyn?
Huh?
Cause that's how it sounds.
Wow.
He does a few like wall law,
the for,
I remember I read it on a software script.
I was like,
Viola,
like view Wah,
Wah,
Wah La,
you know,
French,
French.
Is that right?
Impulse bossy.
Always like,
yeah,
but I mean it's somehow or another it is in English script write stuff down.
So sometimes you have to,
I have to say it in a on a TV show.
I didn't know.
I didn't know and I was like,
oh it's while La,
right?
I thought it was a w,
Travelocity.
I always get that velocity.
No it seamless.
That's fairly simple.
You should go to the doctor checked out.
But Italian man,
what is it about the Italian culture?
Because Italians like are known for first of all like very delicious foods like
delicious,
rich,
fatty,
incredibly good food,
great wine and know for great one art and for being very passionate.
And they all have that crazy way of talking but been anybody.
But if the judge is like,
it's like an art to,
to even communicate it,
it's more when I go back,
I have to retrain myself cause people first,
nobody ever eat,
finish a conversation and let the other person begin to speak is you're
constantly going to interrupt each other.
So it's like that.
Just the norm.
You're not used to it anymore.
So you're like,
oh,
I guess it's your door that he's like,
there's no such thing.
You know you're turning my tribe is,
you'll be 30 CPO to begin to talk taking these gigantic deep breath.
Go ahead.
And then we went this man,
I know it's like indeed God for 10 minutes straight and you're like,
Jesus Christ.
Really?
Do you have all of those and many words in your mouth?
That's insane.
Yes.
I got this photo on my wall and it's from a,
it's an American girl in in Italy.
It's like 1950 something and there's chickens walked down the street and these
dudes grabbing their dicks and like,
it's like,
like what?
You didn't,
I didn't expect this.
People did that.
I thought that was like more of a,
you know,
Jersey shore type thing.
You know?
More of a more recent thing,
but no,
no,
no.
That creepy dudes have been around since the beginning of time.
Since students are created this picture from Italy in 1919 fucking 50 something
I heard somewhere day there were scenes,
particularly northern Europeans who,
you know,
they do many things right.
But definitely the romance department is not the one that they are most.
There are now four.
No a lot.
They're not known for Roman.
Exactly.
So a lot of the women come down for a vacation in Italy to hookup for a random
summer.
Flings exalted.
You could,
oh man,
two key thallium story and then they go back to their regular life.
So who would be the boring like dudes from,
barring is a bad word.
I've got to have a lots of people fly.
But you know they got the reputation for being a little bit on the call and the
selling Norway,
Norway,
Sweden and even Germany.
That's that rep cold.
People that are very disciplined and Trump might not be so good at eating pussy
basically.
Right.
They are going to do it.
You know they are going to make awesome cars are going to run.
They call him,
he,
I eight today we're going to do all the things that Italian can't even begin to
know where to start.
You know,
they do the cars.
Okay.
But not definitely not the economy part,
but when it comes to romance,
yeah,
not quite.
That muscle hasn't been this command.
In order to have a certain amount of fun in the conversation,
there has to be that I don't give a fuck element.
And there's very few like really conservative people that know how to turn that
part on.
Right.
They never know how to not give a fuck.
They don't never know when it's important to not give a phone.
But it's often important to not give a fuck for fun.
Passion for,
for partying,
for,
you know,
just to Jay,
laugh with your friends.
And if you can't do that,
if you can't let that go,
you tightly knit and figuring out how to fucking use gears and leavers in order
to make a car worth better.
That's old time is work,
you know,
after a while,
man.
Yeah.
Even the language.
I mean you tried to say sweet and lovable in Germany.
Yeah.
That was one of the craziest things about Hitler speech.
It wasn't just what he was saying was fucked up.
It was that crazy ass,
the language.
He was saying it in this like really alien,
angry,
you know,
to be an American in the 1940s like when all this was going on and to see that
guy,
I guess they saw him in movie theaters,
right?
And that's how they would see that.
See that guy,
he's screaming at the top of his lungs,
that crazy fucking mustache in that weird language that you didn't understand
that it had to be.
God Damn terrifies here lately man.
Cause you'll see the videos and you see thousands of people standing totally
disciplined.
These stunning,
complete silence to the guy going crazy and don't finish the sentence that you
all jump up with one child.
Wow.
It's insane.
But he seen the men that get to that position,
that,
that crazy position where they can talk a whole gang of people and they're doing
something really,
really bad and everybody's discipline and everybody's along with them.
That's one of those were some of the scariest moments in all of history when
some group or leader with nefarious intentions is like super charismatic,
super driven and super insane altogether and in control.
That's possible.
I would just coming over here,
I was a at stunning two.
I've done card inside his own to the latest a hardcore case study and he was
going off about the story about what was happening in Germany into 59 that has,
yes,
it has like the three ps.
We are the story ever.
It's amazing.
It's,
yeah,
it's I guess it's origins of Lutheranism and what he's talking about was,
I did not know this and this is one of the amazing things about that podcast I
did not know that most people couldn't read.
The Bible is recently as 1500 that
span lt offense in most countries.
If you are ready to buy,
if you own your own Bible,
you read the Bible by yourself,
not in laughing through the priest,
by you.
Instead you had your own thing.
You could be put to that.
That's insane because if you read it on your own,
you'll make a weird ideas and then you would a walked her down the throat and me
sequence through goals ward.
That's not that long ago.
No,
that's not even a thousand years ago.
Yeah,
it's so crazy.
But that's the thing that makes you one that about human beings,
that device,
majority of human beings just go with the program of whatever they are tilting
those times and when you look at that,
like even if you look back 70 years and you look at racism in the United States,
anybody went along with the norm of what was tp called the medic on society 70
years ago.
It would be seen as like batshit crazy today and yet back then,
you know there were plenty of people against it but they were the minority.
The majority of people were like,
yeah of course it does die and people of color and that I heard,
I was like,
it's weird.
It's like people that are donkey's being trained with the carrot and the stick
since they are barn and they just go into PR,
they don't question or shit.
Well people,
it's super easy for people to believe some crazy shit as long as the people
around you believe crazy shit as well.
Exactly.
We have a real problem like that where we can get sucked into our atmosphere and
you,
especially if you are a an easily led person or a person who doesn't have like a
really fully formed opinion of the world.
I mean that's one of the one things they do to people when they torture him and
say they take away your view of the world.
They take away though,
they'd take away your ability to look at things rationally and then when they
start talking to you,
it's like now they're your friends.
Like it says that Stockholm Syndrome,
right?
When they kidnap people,
the kidnapper becomes someone who you love,
you,
you give in,
you relent,
you know.
And that's why they,
that's why that in that homeland show,
like that concept works,
that they'd kidnap these guys and turn them into suicide bond,
these American Gis,
which is pretty creepy fucking premise and scary premise.
But the idea is that like people change if you change their environment
like big time.
The thing,
that's why to me the healthiest thing anybody can do about anything east
requests every single hour totes.
Not because you are like a pain in the ass teenager.
We just want to be different for the hell of being different just because
precisely if you value something you should question it.
It's the same thing as like when you say on the [inaudible] you tried them,
you check it out for yourself if you work.
So you go for it.
If it doesn't,
you don't is it has to be by direct experience.
Otherwise he should start going by the shit that other people tell you.
And,
uh,
it's about belief and going on fate almost out of faculty to know anyway.
The real problem with that is that should be the way we do it.
We should go on other people.
The problem is there's too many diamonds there.
There's
too many people out there that don't know what the fuck was going on in their
own life and they can't give you advice and they can't give you an honest
assessment of whether something works or doesn't work as good or it's not good.
Right?
But that should be the way we go on it.
And it should be.
It should be that we can completely trust everybody.
You know,
if we could figure out how to eliminate deception,
that would be one of the best things ever for the human race.
If we could figure out how to eliminate like the,
the need to steal and deception,
those just to those two things alone.
Yeah.
Good luck with [inaudible].
I know.
Earn what you deserve,
you know,
earn what you deserve,
right?
And don't deceive to get there.
Don't lie.
Right?
Whether it's in business or in your personal life,
your friendships.
And when we figure that out,
that's going to be gigantic cause it's really,
that's one of the beauties when people start talking about psychedelics helping
people,
the be one of the beautiful things is that it eliminates the ego and the ego is
the one that's locked in you and all that stupid shit,
right?
The Ego is locking you into your past experiences.
The Ego's locking you into your idea who you are.
And that's,
that's the kind of shit that allows people to do creepy things.
That's what allows people to steal and to see eve and you know,
use trickery and the,
that's the,
that's someone who's like your ego's allowing you to do that.
Like your,
your sense of humanity and justice and what would you,
how would you want the world to behave?
What if everyone's like that by doing it yourself?
Are you giving the green light for everyone to just go straight pirate?
Right.
Do you know how much,
how hard human beings have worked for so fucking long to get ourselves to a
position where we can walk down the street and almost every city in the country
and be reasonably safe when you're driving and you can be reasonably safe
despite the fact that you're dealing with millions and millions and millions of
people.
Well,
when you go rogue,
you know you,
you conduct this whole awesome system that everybody's been busting their ass.
Big Time to me is weird because my relationship with the low,
I guess is I break the law.
That's the law for thanks for her to translation.
Very good.
The little,
as I was saying,
had to so many fucking words.
I can say
there are lots of lows.
I break on a fairly regular basis,
but my,
I guess moral stand standpoint on that is anything,
anything I do,
whether legal or illegal,
the end result can't be hurting another human being.
If anybody walked home crying because of something that I did is fuck it up,
you find,
but it came to those that don't really hurt another human being.
There's not one person who is going to shed a tear over it,
then I have no problem with it.
Well,
I agree with that.
If you're like run a red light three in the morning when there's no one around.
Right?
But I think even if,
if certain laws like like financial laws,
there was a reason why people are willing to steal things from their,
their job and people were willing to lie about their taxes when people,
and one of the reasons is that regular people,
people who are worried about their money and scratch and scrape and save for
vacations,
if they ever get a vacation,
regular people see the type of shit that goes on on Wall Street.
They see like those houses in the Hamptons on those TV shows and those,
those crazy places in Greenwich,
Connecticut where these people have fucking airports and their backyard and
helicopter landing pads in the middle of their polo field.
You know,
it's insane money.
You're talking about people who have hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars,
so many of them.
And what,
what do they offer?
What did they do?
While they're in the financial business,
they move numbers around.
They figured out a way to extract money from the system.
That's what they do.
They get really good at extracting money from the system.
And the best piece of evidence is what's in front of them.
Right?
What exactly do you do?
You move numbers,
you buy,
you sell,
you do this,
you that.
How the fuck have you acquired the amount of wealth that you need to,
to own a gigantic compound in Greenwich,
Connecticut.
What benefit have you given?
What have you done there?
What have you done?
You've extracted money from the system.
That's what you've done.
Whether it's legal or illegal,
the uh,
the,
it's the same shit because you know,
the laws that are in place are only in place because somebody bribed somebody
and that's a fact.
Somebody you special interest money to make something happen somewhere that
somebody liked that somebody passed that law and got things through.
And that's how,
that's how the system is set up the way it is.
Yeah.
That's how,
I mean,
if you're going to be in the game anyway,
Dan,
I have no problem.
But they cane syrup and lows,
but I don't break my own lows.
You know what I mean?
It's social loads.
Fuck it.
Whatever.
As long as by my stock.
The problem is when people,
when people stop being goody goody and go by the book to fucking booty goodies.
Okay.
They at bet [inaudible] they uh,
they just go nuts.
Right?
So it's like he's not just,
the date is likely break a few lows because those laws don't make sense is they
go all out and do the rape and pillage and whatever the fight or day out or
these goody goody for the eggs to are.
And both of them don't.
I mean,
I prefer the one that's not going to shoot you at 3:00 AM,
but at the end of the day they bought our stock in this dogmatic view offered a
word about how it's supposed to be.
And to me,
once you break clothes,
you have to be,
there's a Bob Dylan line in one of his songs that he say to leave outside the
law.
You must be honest,
which just sounded like it buyer paradox,
right?
Because it's saying what the fuck are you mean?
Like I already going to be honest with a better King Louis and he really is
unique to be,
otherwise you're turn into some fuck it up.
Could he mean?
Uh,
but if you're going to do it,
you need to have some three TC or use,
uh,
Morrell safeguard that you have on your own.
Then you don't need any God or call to catch you to make you not do it is you
don't do certain things because they are fucked up period and you are just not
going to do it.
Cause it's such,
what's the inside of you?
That's a very romantic notion,
man.
That's like a fucking clinics Eastwood movie.
You know,
it is a romantic notion of the,
the,
the ethics of being an outlaw outlaw ethics.
I realize a few days ago I was,
uh,
I was,
you don't want to like,
Facebook has the sig like inspirational people or shit like that play in.
You throw down some names.
I realize I put down Robin Hood to twice.
I was like shit really twice that impart that to me at different point in time.
I'm like okay,
I see it back there near and I didn't know that Robin Hood was initially about
poaching.
Yeah.
It's about food.
Right.
Cause they didn't let her hand,
they wouldn't let the poor hunt on the land.
So these poor,
they have no money and no food and they started shooting deer in Robin hood
would shoot these deer and give them to poor people.
Yup.
Such silly matches the fact that king's ever worked at that ever worked that
anybody was ever willing to like admit your grace royalty.
You know,
that's one of the beautiful things about that.
And I know it's a fantasy novel,
but um,
uh,
game of Thrones is the way the communicate with each other,
the way the royals like have this secret guarded way of communicating with each
other.
But the actors are so good that he's like,
the intention is like very clear throughout everything and they have,
it's very proper way of handling and managing every situation.
It's so fascinating.
That show is awesome.
It's so that royal blood thing is such a trip and I again,
I know that this is just a TV show that's bullshit.
They got dragons and stuff.
You know,
it's not,
there's no reality,
but no,
the Aclu is really,
that idealistic way of communicating did exist at least in small places.
In small pockets for quite a while.
Right?
Absolutely.
But the thing is not only why we to volts,
that part is actually the coolest part about it is how it devolves that one day
some guy shows up and say,
you know a lot of,
I'm going to be your keen.
You'd call me Your Majesty and he's not because God wants it to be that way.
And I mean if I go do that around today,
I probably don't have such success.
How to fuck it.
If people go along with that,
it's just amazing.
It's,
I don't know it.
Do you think that being a king and that that kind of thing comes from the
original Alpha male primate behavior that that chimps exhibit and monkeys
exhibit where there's one that's always the alpha.
So almost like we have this weird broken need to have that one.
So we go,
we go looking for it.
Whether it's right,
whether it's a king or a priest or a,
you know,
whatever.
Whoever there's a one or you know,
could it be that way?
Could also be and one doesn't exclude.
The other back would also be like in hunting and gathering societies,
which is how we have lived the majority of time we've been around.
You have to kind of have these informed my leadership because there's only like
2030 people I have known each other their life.
So when there's a decision to be made,
everybody turned to you because you are cool.
They are smart.
Last time you'll give us good advice.
You want to have real power.
But when you sat down and you started eating farming income,
you only under 30 people
become 300 and then they'll come 3000 there's a lot more of those little in
their fights.
You know,
people within the tribe would start fighting each other and so you need the
leader to come mediate cause he's a cool guy but it stops being OER.
Nice guy.
You do that once in a while.
It becomes a full time job and it becomes so important to keep the society to
gather and make sure that people don't kill each other.
And it's like you know what?
Stop planting your fields.
Don't worry about that.
We understand that it's a pain in the ass for you to constantly be having to
worry about our little squabbles.
But it's such an important job we'll plant for you.
You know,
and suddenly there's a division of social class.
It's where suddenly somebody is a specialized job or that emerge.
Maybe because they are cold people maybe starts out at people give them that
power,
right?
Hey man,
you got to read these mites.
You can always solve the problem.
And then would it be Gerda society gets the more to social stratification.
The Morton that position become entrenched,
saw,
they'd unquestionable the passes to their kids.
So kings divide,
right?
All of that shit.
But partly the way it starts,
it starts in a mad little normal way.
Like,
Oh man,
you're a cool guy.
You give good advice,
please us mediate.
You know,
and the more the need for mediation increases,
the bigger,
the more important their role becomes until it becomes something above and
separate from everybody else's.
And he's now the leadership by charisma anymore.
It becomes leadership by Bert or some shit
by right.
By divine right.
By enforcement of the group of people that agrees with you.
And then you divvy up power within the group.
Yup.
Yeah.
It's madness.
It's a,
it's amazing that it existed as the norm though.
What's amazing is that it's not just that in one place a king was born right and
they had a king and wow,
this is crazy.
How did they do at King thing?
Nobody else would agree with that.
Yeah,
no,
it,
everybody agreed to it.
They agreed to it all over the world.
Yeah.
It's the green to the emperor in China.
They had an emperor in Japan.
I mean every,
basically everybody was rocking that king thing at one time.
I mean that's amazing.
Yeah.
You can't have a big society without central authority.
It sounded off all awful to say because it sounded like you're defending some
fascist model of the world.
Whereas like the stronger,
again,
I'm not going to do the purpose like we a device,
but the
need for a center [inaudible] to keep the society in check and unfortunately
when you put enough people together is not going to work unless you have some
kind of central authority.
Could kind of decide is sings.
That's the long
chess game of the new world order when the,
if you think about it,
why would you ever want the world to be stable?
Because if the world was stable,
you would need some sort of militarize government to protect you.
Right?
So the militarized government that's protecting you,
make sure the world's days on stable absolutely keeps the party rolling.
Because if everybody just agrees to settle the fuck down and stop killing each
other,
then you don't really need as many jets.
You don't have as many resources,
as much resources to go into war.
There's all sorts of shit you could solve.
Complex locked into the grip of this constantly feeding machine that constantly
has momentum working in the same direction.
And it does.
There's money to be made in it.
It's not like it's a just an altruistic adventure to try to fix the world and
engineer it properly.
No,
no.
Everybody's making money.
It's staggering amounts.
It's the best money making thing in the whole world.
That's what I mean.
That whole speech by highs and hour in the 50s it was a,
because every,
you know,
Eisenhower,
Republican guy was led,
uh,
troops in world war two.
You know,
not the most conspiracy theory in Klein.
he's a very straight by the book kind of guy.
And yet when he announces,
you know,
the biggest threat facing the United States in the 50 70 buddy said,
well communism,
right?
No military industrial complex.
It's like the fuck are you talking about again and you know the guys and
military guy himself,
a fairly conservative guy and yet he makes,
Nicole is saying if you let certain industries that trough it on war get too
big,
they will get to have influence over government push in as to fight wars when we
don't really need it because of their own profit.
And you know,
if he comes from some random hippie that your is like yeah,
whatever,
you know it comes from this straight lace,
the by the book kind of guys.
Like Whoa,
really?
You know when I first found that out I,
that I saw that speech,
I was really pissed that no one ever showed it to me in high school.
They never did.
No,
they didn't talk about it.
no.
I never came up in my high school.
Nobody ever said that.
Eisenhower warned us about the military industrial complex,
the concept of the military industrial complex being anything but good or the
military and being anything but good is never taught.
It was never taught when I was in high school and not in my school and I was
going to,
I went to Newton south high school,
which was a very good high school in the suburbs of Boston.
It's a very good school,
very smart kids and any of that.
No,
there's no idea it was there was never like [inaudible].
That's a really sort of uh,
that,
that that's a very controversial subject to be teaching children.
It's fun though.
That's what it's about.
They are going to pay attention to that.
They are not going to pay attention if you say the you then team uh,
18 but I mean controversial in that a lot of parents are going to think that
that's like liberal programming and then what you're doing is bullshitting these
kids with your hippie ideas and you're fucking with my kid's head.
And it's like I'm the reporting what some Republican precedent was a or in world
war two said,
yeah,
back off.
Yeah.
That's still though.
It's such a,
it's such a,
at least it was when I was in high school.
It's such a sensitive area to choose the government of doing anything nefarious
that was never done.
Like when I was in high school,
they taught us Lee Harvey Oswald shot fucking Canada.
Oh yeah,
they did.
They did.
It was right.
That's exactly what it was.
They showed you Lee Harvey Oswald and they showed Jack Ruby killing Lee Harvey
Oswald Gall.
Darn it.
We'll never even know now why he killed the president.
Like they taught us that in high school,
and this is like years after they had the Zapruder film shown on the Geraldo
Rivera Show where I'm Dick Gregory,
the standup comedian brought it on the Geraldo Rivera show and showed people
the,
the view of the assassination from essentially a,
where this guys is uprooted was standing,
which we had never seen the actual assassination before.
And when people watched it,
the first thing they thought was that this guy looks like he's been shot from
the front.
Right?
Like it doesn't look like he got his head goes back into the left.
Like he got shot by more than one person too.
He got shot in his back.
He got shot.
There's,
there's a a one wound that they turned into a tracheotomy wound,
right?
Yeah,
it was a,
it was an entry room from the front.
It was a,
there was a bullet room and do it.
Whereas neck was,
and there's two different depictions of the autopsy from Bethesda,
Maryland to Dallas.
It's really interesting.
It is.
It's very interesting stuff.
I guess what you were saying,
it puts things in perspective for me because there are a bunch of times when I'm
teaching class and told me,
I'm saying this things that are the most nor most things that everybody would
know and I see everybody kind of like Joel dropped to the ground like,
oh,
what the fuck really that happened?
I'm like,
yeah,
it does.
It definitely isn't that kind of the stuff that you normally teach and I guess
no,
it's not.
No,
it's not at all.
No.
The normal in school,
you're taught no conspiracy theories.
You were taught no variations of the truth.
You know,
you,
you're,
you're taught enough.
I mean,
as the most controversial it gets is a,
Nixon was involved in a scandal in Watergate,
you know,
they tell you a Nixonian that's good though.
Cause they got rid of next.
He did a bad thing.
This guy,
apparently Nixon had loose morals.
Did you ever listen to all those Nixon tapes?
Like there's like hundreds and hundreds of hours of tapes because they had every
thing might in the whole entire place.
Right.
And there's like things where like,
uh,
he talks about abortion.
I just heard this not opening Anthony the other day and there's just like parts
where he's talking about abortion and stuff like that,
you know,
just in case of like,
you just listen to it.
It's crazy.
There's not a lot of creepy shit.
Creepy shit
creep.
He was a creep and they found out about it by,
by,
you know,
tapping into his fucking,
oh he's the president.
Oh yeah,
he knew about it.
They knew they were recording all that.
I'm responsible for it.
No,
he was responsible.
He had everything Mike,
because he wanted to,
if anything was to happen,
he wanted to have proof.
So he was like the good guy.
And,
and what happened is that they just recorded everything and found,
you know,
bugged the campaign quarter headquarters.
So what these guys did,
they bagged the democratic campaign and in order to find out what they were
saying and when they got busted,
that was this kind of,
because it's like you out arise by keynote,
that's totally illegal.
And he said,
no,
it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
And then eventually come out that it was exactly the recording is referring to
where there's a lot of evidence of what Nixon was actually saying that he did do
that shit.
People need to know if there are precedents or crook,
I'm not a crook.
And that Nico lately afterwards fables that he said,
well,
if the president does it then it's not illegal.
I just like
you don't get them by.
Did he really say that?
Well,
he was a creepy dude.
Anyway.
The,
the weirdest thing about him being president is that is the leader of this great
nation.
That's the best you can do.
That guy's weird man.
That guy,
he's everything about him.
Looks like you made it with a stamp,
you know,
crested in a mold.
It looks like he polished it up and it though the whole like is everything was
weird about that guy.
Everything,
the way they walk,
the way weight talked
big time.
I tend to trust the intuition in that regard,
at least on a person to person alive.
It like you see somebody and before they say anything you've got to vibe before
you've seen there is something we are toward the person or not.
Man,
look,
you didn't Nixon,
you
got it.
How the fuck did he become president?
That's what I'm saying.
As you look at him,
he's like one of the creepiest guys ever elected to like a major office.
Why don't you go arms up in the air.
He's a weird looking dude and it looks so awkward and he didn't feel warm.
He didn't feel real.
He didn't feel,
there was nothing about him than me.
Like with Kennedy,
Kennedy had like,
it was obvious he was a special man.
Like it was obviously,
it was this handsome man of great lineage,
you know?
And he had this way of talking and this charisma,
that's all he could see it right there.
It's all real obvious.
But you get to a guy like Nixon and he'd go,
what the fuck was going on there,
man?
And he's funny because he got elected in 1968 which is uniting the mid bill off
the 60s it's Betty.
And he's precisely because the 60 sort of going on,
the Conservatives got freaked diodes and they started,
oh my God,
the country is going in this crazy,
wild,
godless liberal direction.
We need to take it back.
Hardcore politically organized to try to act.
And they got Nixonian office.
Yeah.
But yeah,
man,
Nixon is a three.
If they say that the election of 1960 was the first election where they add the
debate was on TV and that they had,
uh,
four,
um,
they say that people would really,
it on the radio to the debate think that Nixon had done pretty well,
but then people will watch it on TV.
They overwhelmingly thought Kennedy dominated cause he's so handsome.
Exactly.
And that he looked good by comparison,
whereas Nixon was like these weird looking thrawled that was scary as hell on so
many ways.
And so anybody watching on TV,
it was like,
fuck that guy.
He was sweating like a pig.
He was doing all that.
It's like
that's instinctive.
I,
it shouldn't be,
but it's instinctive.
There's,
I mean it's not,
it's not even an appearance thing cause Rodney Dangerfield was kind of an ugly
dude,
but he was so lovable and warm.
You know what I mean?
I mean if Rodney Dangerfield had the creepy behavior of Nixon,
he would be just as creepy,
of course is like Nixon lacked any charisma.
When,
when you tell people,
you know,
Oh,
you trust first impressions,
they were like,
whoa,
that's superficial.
They are only looking at somebody as good looking or not.
It's not even about that is there's a vibe to people.
There's,
to me,
I'm a big believer of that.
I don't know exactly what you see.
I don't know if you some specific about the language.
I don't know what is that you see,
but to me is every single I've ever gone through his return on your skin.
You know he's right in New Zealand now you'll move.
Is it now your talk is in now you're do every since.
So it shows up and to me is not weird that some people can see it.
It's like why the fuck can't,
most people see it as like a Chihuahua and this isn't the fuel for 30 seconds
and decide exactly Barca to you or be all like,
you know,
it's like if a Chihuahua I can do it.
Yeah,
but let me tell you something.
Two hours are wrong all the time.
They bark constantly.
They're not the best.
That's not the best faculty for a dog.
That doesn't qualify as a dog anyway.
But that is true.
The dog sniff you out and learn things about you and people.
Yeah,
Ken too.
When you have a,
we have a weird way of,
you know whether or not you trust it and whether or not it's tuned in.
You know,
you got to have a,
been around plenty of crazy people and be taken a really good look at your own
self,
look at yourself like really truly objectively your fault,
all of it to be able to recognize it in other people because if you're
bullshitting yourself,
it's super easy to get bullshitted course.
Of course.
Yeah.
And if you're bullshit bullshitting other people,
it's also easy to get bullshitted cause you know,
you like that.
That was like a big thing and gambling was the double dump when a guy thought he
was getting dumped,
but really they were dumping on him.
You know,
the double dump where you know you're manipulating how a a game goes down.
Right.
People are devious little fucks.
Are you sure are?
Well not all of them.
A lot of them.
Lots of them.
Good percentage.
Yeah.
Give you that.
Once we read each other's minds,
that shit's all going to stop.
Yeah.
I think that,
I think that's the next step.
The next step of evolution is going to be knowing whether or not someone's
bullshitting.
Yeah.
Oh,
save so much.
But to me that's,
I dunno.
Maybe I'm too like,
Ooh,
psychic powers or some shit about,
to me that's not even that hard to do now let alone like to me,
what about that Jodie areas?
Well,
I mean,
that's what I mean is that,
let me tell you something son.
She would've Gotcha.
Gotcha.
Chin.
She was cute enough that you would say,
you know,
she wants to be with me.
I'm going to take a chance.
You'll be in there with their Tam and like,
she doesn't look like an obvious freak.
There's nothing that's cream freak freak.
No,
no.
I mean,
just like,
we are like,
oh,
stop you in the shower.
Kind of fatigue.
But as azine she does look freakishly cold.
Like there's something there that's like,
there's something weird going on emotionally,
so I wouldn't be able to tell.
Oh yeah,
she's this weird a wanna be,
but you could that like,
Huh,
there's something off there.
That bitch is Correy
did you see the um,
the video,
the security video of her after they arrested her?
No,
I didn't say it louder.
Headstands and headstands singing to herself like they're locking her up in a
cage
for the rest of their life for murder and probably going to put her to death.
Right.
And she's singing.
Yep.
And then when they asked her from jail,
like they have a jailhouse interview.
It's stunning how well she lies about this.
And you know,
it's a beautiful thing that people do so well when they lie about shit like
that.
Well,
how are you staying calm?
My faith.
Just think about that statement that your faith after you stabbed a dude like 28
times,
shot him in the head,
slit his neck.
Like this bitch did some crazy shit to this guy's body.
Yup.
And she's like my faith.
It makes me think she actually believes it when she saved my faith.
I think there's a good chunk of pharaoh actually believe what she's saying.
She could be one of those people that's so crazy that they sorta reformed their
reality every three or four hours.
There's people like that.
I've seen people that have um,
been able to justify almost anything because they just sort of put it away and
then there's a new reality,
you know,
I've never done anything like that.
Like you just did it.
What the fuck you talking about like this?
There's a lot of people that are like that.
They could just shut parts of the brain off and unfortunately I think a lot of
them suffered childhood abuse.
Yeah.
In fact,
that's the thing that's sometimes,
you know,
when you've got the whole background story,
you almost feel bad,
but then you know,
you feel bad for the five year old.
You don't feel bad for the person you have become because it's like,
I understand how you got there,
but understanding doesn't mean justifying.
Exactly.
It's too fucked up.
Sorry Ken,
let that slot.
Absolutely.
It's just there's certain things as a race we have to figure out how to stop it
from occurring and I don't think we put any resources into that.
It's amazing how much we put resources into making sure that marijuana stays
illegal.
Think about how much money is involved in that.
What is it,
4 billion a year or something like that.
It's crazy.
Something nutty.
And how,
how much have we really put into trying to help people?
They're doing a shitty job of raising their children.
How much,
I mean,
besides like what,
I don't know what you can do really.
I mean besides actively going in there and taking their kids away,
you know,
but it just some form of education,
some community centers,
something.
I just feel like when you see like really,
really poor neighborhoods that are ignored,
you're just asking for problems.
Of course you're just asking for problems.
You should fix that.
Level that up as much as possible.
Help those people out as much as possible and help them to get the fuck out of
there.
And the,
the,
the thing that drives me crazy about people when they talk about people that are
in the ghetto,
like,
oh,
they're poor and they're lazy.
That's why they're still on welfare.
You know,
if they don't want to work,
you don't,
you don't get it.
You don't get it.
They are in a shit spot.
And it's super hard to have a good mentality when you're in a shitty spot.
It's very hard to see.
So to say that they,
you know,
it was just fucking get off their lazy your eyes and stop collecting welfare.
You're,
I think you're probably missing what's going on in there,
you know,
ideology aside,
right wing rhetoric aside,
you're,
you're dealing with someone who got a terrible roll the dice and that could have
been you,
man.
You could have been in that.
And just because you can pull out a story or two or three about people who are
in that situation.
And then rob went on to get his phd and to this day he says that living in the
ghetto does not hold you back.
It's a prison of your own mind,
right?
It's like there's always those stories.
But the reality is how much good role models to those kids have.
How many good role models,
how much good inspiration,
how much hope for the future.
Student of mine,
a very first semester I started teaching it was this guy was from south central
La and we started to chat enough their words and Matt and his stories.
He would tell me about what was normal buyer day to day life.
It'd be like yeah,
yesterday you didn't get home until midnight from class cause they had somebody
killed the write down my door and so they had lock it up with a whole bunch just
like fuck really?
And that shit would look at and like three times a year.
Yeah.
It happens all the time.
Real dangerous.
Who,
you know,
running into the wrong vehicle.
It's all real dangerous.
Yup.
And you know,
one's doing shit about it and you know,
they do.
All they do about it is they arrest people when people do things that are bad,
you know,
instead of making cops lives way easier.
And this is all very utopian hippy.
We need to fix it.
We needed to do something,
go together.
But it's just weird to me that it never comes up.
It's weird to me that if you do bring it up,
oh it's socialism and and people cry like tents.
There's a bunch of babies there,
man.
There's like a whole community of,
of a,
of future people that you can affect.
This is,
he was a whole new generation of future people that if emphasis is put on
helping it can,
how it can somehow or another we could figure out a way to like at least
eliminate a certain aspect aspect
of the lowest of our lowest class society.
You know,
it seems like that could be done with education.
It seems like at least part of it can be done.
Sure.
Definitely better than it is currently.
At least we just not say much but only stairs.
It's just one of the most frustrating things is how far we've come as a human
race and yet how far we have to go when it comes to shit like that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Cause,
I mean the whole nine fuzzy Sony individuality,
Nisha TV's like pull yourself up by your bootstrap and stuff.
There's something good about that of course that he's an adamant about self
empowerment that the regardless of circumstances,
you know you're not going to try to change their code status says suggests cause
you wish it so that he's an and where they interviewed.
Whether it needs to find a way because if nothing else is doing it for you,
you might as well do your best to do it.
But having said that,
most people then use that argument to Disney.
So the social conditions,
it becomes a,
well it's just up to you.
We'll show goes on,
we are all behind you kind of shit is.
In the meantime you start from 50 behind everyone
else because you've got to weigh up in a shitty place with drug abuse all over
with alcohol abuse all over with neural models with the whole thing.
And he's like,
bye,
you know you can do it.
I said,
well yeah,
sweet.
Sweet of you to say it wasn't,
you know,
you haven't grown up in that shit.
It's such a cliche,
but a chain is only as strong as its weakest link.
And if we really,
you know,
the most patriotic thing that we could do as a country is not go fuck with some
other countries overseas with dubious intentions,
but,
but strengthen our weakest link,
the weakest economic link or weakest social thing.
It's like that's a,
it's a,
it's a weird thing that politicians don't talk about that,
but they don't offer that up as a plan for the future take,
you know,
but give country,
give companies contracts to clean up the ghetto,
right.
The same kind of contracts you give to clean up fucking Iraq.
Give contracts to clean up again though,
it'd be amazing,
Glenn,
let Halbert and make money cleaning up the ghetto.
W W why can't they do that?
And I don't,
I don't understand why I can't profit off of that.
It seems ridiculous and it seems like it's just at this point in time,
2013 we're still doing the same goddamn shit.
Still going over to countries get involved and dubious shit.
Right.
Somehow or another it can or can't be tied to resources and oil and this and
that.
And Barlage,
conspiracy theory were over there and stop it as long from taking over our
underwear,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's like the same God damn shell game.
Yep.
Wow.
I mean in fact that's what's fun.
Yeah.
I guess I keep thinking you don't have today,
but that's because you started on him.
We'd done Carly and I was gonna Faint.
We see it is about the Roman republic.
Yeah.
Mario's cause he was the same exact dynamics.
You see
them today.
Yeah.
Buy The book.
Exactly.
Vulnerable.
It's unavoidable.
It's such,
we're stupid.
We're broken.
We're broken little crazy animals.
We don't know how to like keep it together.
We get,
we get it together for a certain amount of time and then we fucking spiral out
of control and just slamming into the rocks.
It's a fucking weird because I don't know,
I mean not these,
when,
uh,
when I look at myself and I analyze like where I'm at,
I'm happy with me or not.
I see so much fucking room for improvement.
There are lots of times they were like,
Eh,
you know I,
I'm glad you see it cause I've been meaning to talk to you about your,
but
I see a lot of it.
I like myself.
There are good things,
but I also see like,
ah fuck this thing is not so good.
They see in Ghana it's a weakness.
Then I look at everyone else and I'm like fuck,
I'm a god.
That's going to be a meme on the Internet for sure.
Then I look at everyone else and I'm like,
fuck,
I'm a god.
That is a meme and a half.
So I need just fuck yourself.
You just fucked yourself hard.
You better hope and pray you don't say anything stupid for the next three years
because that's how long they remember a meme for.
So good,
let's do it.
And I look at everyone else and I'm like,
fuck,
I'm a god.
The thing that's funny is it's not that
I really think like I'm all that.
Cause when I look at objectively just me,
I do see so many places where I could improve.
But then you know the barriers,
so fucking low on average,
the average human being,
there's so many fucked up shit that people do that I'm like,
wow,
okay,
that's at least right,
right when you think that you're a loser because he can't pay your credit card.
You hear about this guy in Cleveland then as kidnap three women for 10 years and
you go,
oh,
I'm not really a bad person.
Okay.
It's,
yeah,
but that's,
that's why it's important to surround yourself with bad motherfuckers.
That's very important.
You know,
the,
to surround yourself with cool people like one,
one of the things that I've gotten really good at it as I've become an adult,
as I collect cool people,
I know how to collect cool friends.
I got a bunch of cool people that I've managed to sneak into my life.
And that's very important because when you have questions about something,
when you want to talk to somebody about something,
like I can resource a database of cool,
intelligent,
level headed,
you know,
healthy ego people.
That's super important.
So hard to find.
It is.
That's one of the most important things about choosing a place to live or
choosing people to be around is surrounding yourself with inspirational people.
People who also are healthy,
people who are excited,
people have good attitudes.
People aren't lazy bitches.
That's what I already did most called meant.
I see when I look at your board,
when I look at Duncan's board,
like people to see me as where people,
when I send you an email like,
oh,
I love it.
The politics are such that have stuff like that.
So many people say the exact same thing you're saying,
which is Jesus Christ.
I can find around me the kind of conversations that you guys have on.
I thought,
man,
I wish,
and that's why at least them,
because I can't find it around me.
And uh,
you know,
it's amazing.
It's inspiring to be reminded that not all humanities like that.
Well,
you know what it is is a lot of people that think like this,
like us out there,
but there were,
weren't connected by like a show.
It's like they were all floating around and you,
you sort of locked into certain ideologies and sometimes you could listen to
this kind of a show or that kind of a show,
but it,
you know,
it didn't get locked in to where you can all meet up.
It's almost like you need a spot where you meet up and then everybody goes,
I'm not alone.
I'm not crazy.
Yeah,
this world is fucked.
Thank you.
Cause I get up every day and I look at my alarm clock and I go,
what the fuck is the point?
And going to my whack ass job.
Right.
Well this is a crazy fucked up world.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
And I'm just stuck in the system,
which eats up most of my time and therefore leaves me with no time to really
think about what I'm doing.
So I'm just caught a creature of momentum floating down the river life,
trying to figure out a way to get to a lily pad and just catch a breath.
Fuck me.
Fuck man.
So,
you know,
that's one of the best things about living in la.
It's said,
I know so many cool people that live around here.
It's one of the only thing that keeps me around.
Yup.
So,
so,
so important and so important to do it through podcast too.
You know,
when we do it,
when we bring you these people,
you guys out there listening,
we'll bring you these people like Danielle,
they ballet La,
Joe Diaz and Duncan Trussell.
You know,
that stuff.
Uh,
when,
when that,
when it spreads like that,
like I said,
it's good for everybody.
That's good for all of us.
Yeah.
Cause I mean imagine yard the guy,
we're leave seen a town of 2000 people,
I don't know,
Nebraska or something.
Yeah.
And you hired a,
everybody you'd relate to feel like they live in a parallel universe.
I feel like you're the weird,
before Internet you would have been really fucked with Internet.
You can have access to a holiday or award out there.
We were like,
okay,
I'm not exactly all the crazy one in town.
There really is something different.
You can share it with other people.
In your town too.
You can say,
listen,
this dude named Duncan Trussell and you gotta hear this fucking podcast and it's
going to change the way you look at marriage.
Or I flashlights don't for a fleshlight.
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's what the Internet provides that nobody had before.
Yeah.
You know,
that's one of the things that was really fascinating about this Dan Carlin
podcast as he was talking about Martin Luther and how they printed up.
This is a amazing stuff folks.
They made these little like pamphlets and they handed out these pamphlets,
um,
uh,
about religion and people would hide them and share them with each other and
they were,
they were like secret,
like through,
and it's spread like a wildfire.
This guy,
Martin Luther,
he was the first guy that to translate the Bible in a phonetic language,
the first guy to make it so that the people who didn't understand Latin could
actually read the word of the Bible.
Yeah.
Cause at that time when he started doing that,
he was a death penalty offense all nearby Borlaug and read it in,
you know,
could he stay uncommon?
Three she was bad,
bad,
but you gotta be a priest because all of the epar yeast can read it correctly.
If you read it on your own,
you're going to screw syncs up and pollute the word of God and back then the
pope had bitches.
Of course the pope had mistresses.
What's the point of being a corporate cash?
The pope was going to war with the Mongols.
Yeah,
no,
actually the pope went to war with the Romans.
Right.
Does it who went through war?
The popo let it all [inaudible] of course.
Yeah.
There were guys Elian of these stories where sometime before they became pope
they were like Janet Larson shapes as loader,
a whole town and that adventure or a whole town and become a pope sometime
sometime when they were actually popes pope and being a priest in general
becomes so gay.
Not to say anything wrong with that,
but I think like throw out,
it was the only cover that you add if you need them to have a eight data with
sexuality where he'll get married and you just have Keach and don't have that
shaky.
She just wasn't in year one.
You couldn't fake it.
And it's not like you had the option of saying,
no,
sorry,
I,
I'm out of days cause I like to do it's or something.
You couldn't say that.
So do you just teach poetry and everybody would just give you a wink and they
knew what was up.
Not even because everybody's expected to get married or not married and you
don't have kids.
The fuck is wrong with you.
If you become a priest,
he's your only cover is,
oh,
because it's,
I mean the service of God.
Then it's like,
oh,
okay.
That's why you don't touch.
We meant and stuff.
How many men back then must have had beards,
beards,
meanings,
wives that weren't really their wife.
They just,
they had a why just for the,
even fucked her and got her pregnant healthworks.
Really?
They would just,
how can boody every night planning to plan to plan far toward world.
That's only 15 hundreds of total thing that Martin Luther Shit was nuts.
Yup.
MMM.
And that people that didn't think he took it far enough.
Yeah,
they took it to another level.
Right.
What was it called again and the one that had a baptism.
Baptism.
Yeah.
And even those guys that are like so many subdivision,
that's why this thing gets so crazy.
Cause you know,
most of those guys are hardcore pacifist to sort of read the New Testament in a
very literal,
you know,
turn the other cheek,
love your enemies so they wouldn't fight under any conditions.
But then there were some guys who decided,
well I liked Sam of your interpretation,
which was the more brutal pooler semi communist interpretation of the New
Testament.
But these peaceful shit.
Yeah,
I don't like that pirates.
So we'll just go forward a hardcore but oh poo or pro communist approach by,
we'll just bash bust outside selling the way people's thing.
Exactly.
They decided that there would be no private property and they wanted to own,
but like no one should be able to own anything.
You know,
just like we all enjoy fire.
We all enjoy the sun.
Like they were going deep.
Some of the stories that are just,
you can't believe that people go along with you.
Well,
I can't believe that in 1500 you couldn't even read a Bible.
That is amazing.
I didn't know that.
And that give you an idea of how much of an institution designed to control
people.
The Catholic Church was fired.
I'm mad at ease.
It just how you can get away with it since the beginning of time.
Yeah,
no,
it's crazy.
It really is insane.
And in that sense that was the coolest thing about Martin Luther is about
pushing these.
Everybody can make it decide for themselves,
which sound very sweet and Democrat.
I take it.
But the problem is that then when he started realizing that either people were
interpreting the Bible in ways that were completely unlike he's,
he was justice piece.
There's the Catholic with them.
It's like,
no,
I meant Fredo from the Catholic interpretation.
I didn't mean to really make up your own.
That's sub.
We are shit.
They are interpreted narrow who don't do that and put all of this done,
start to burdening people at the stake just as much as Catholics who are doing
it well.
That was the big time for Brandon people.
Yeah.
The Guy,
John Calvin,
like the sacrum major Fieger beside Martin Luther among the Protestants.
He was so pissed with this one guy because he denied the trinity.
You know the father song.
It goes thing that he had been burned at the stake and when they were bringing
the wood to set him on fire,
he said,
no,
not that word.
That's dry.
He's going to burn up quick.
I want in Greenwood.
I want this motherfucker to last a long time.
That God really,
that's the guy who was tired.
A huge branch of Protestantism.
He's Greenwood.
Yeah,
cause that weight eat longer.
Long time.
Yup.
They cooked the guy to death with Greenwood.
I could just see a slow fire cooking your feet,
which is like Oh mother fucker to you have to be too watery.
Diarrhea.
Yeah.
There was a lot of green mountain grill.
I met the owner by the way,
within a Sacramento.
Oh did you?
We went drinking and got wasted at some wasted with the owner of green mountain
grill.
It's a great grill.
I think she's mine the other night.
I love it.
I cooked some of the last of my venison sausage.
This is amazing.
It's so cause you keep the temperature of the same.
We went from Martin Luther and we're going to talk about cooking people.
Well,
yeah.
That is a fucked up part about history as the cruelty that people were willing
to do to their fellow man.
You know,
it can just feel years ago in the name of ideology.
I mean this is not even the stuff where he's like,
Amen.
You have a lot of cool gold.
I wanted,
sorry luck.
I'll bash bashers Coleen cause I want to take it.
It's not nice,
but you can see a logic to it.
At least this is about some,
you don't believe in the trinity.
That's what I'm going to burn you to that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Really?
That's what we argue about.
The father,
the son and the holy girls.
Yeah.
Your daughters raped killer.
Well there wasn't a Catholic church.
That's more of a Islamic approach,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
but the thing is that what scares me to me is not even one group or the other is
like anybody who will put side,
they all g I bill of a reality.
Individuals around them,
anybody will go towards anybody.
In that sense.
To me ideology,
any kind of ideology in that sense is that disease because the radio then
interpreting life by looking at what really is going on,
you're trying to interpret it to this field.
They're off your debts to feed my preconceived notion of the universe and life
does,
and then there's something wrong with life.
I'm going to disregard a tabby dance cause I got it all figured out.
It can be beneficial if you follow a really positive ideology,
but just following an ideology itself is so dangerous.
Yep.
It's like the idea that one person or one idea,
one thought will prevail above all,
despite rational changes in your environment,
changes around you.
When,
when and that's what a religion really is a religion.
It's an ideology that's,
that's where it really becomes a problem.
We get locked into those too easy for some reason.
It's like a broken circuit.
We have like,
you know,
it's me and it's like we have like a,
a defect.
I think life is too complex for most people to deal with.
There are too many exceptions.
There's too much change going on.
So what was working yesterday may not work today and it's too much.
It's too much work.
People don't want to deal with it.
So one of the things that people dig is the ability to have some solid dogma to
fall back on.
That is reassuring,
makes them feel good about life.
It makes them feel like I know what's going on as opposed to be constantly on
the boulder and if you go to Saint [inaudible] as you'll go.
Yeah.
Especially folks that seem to have,
you know,
like a little extra fear or a less curiosity
or they get tired easier,
you know,
it's so easier for them to just a lock on it.
So I'm going also be easier for people that are mentally ill to lock onto
something.
That's the one of the weirdest things when you see obviously mentally ill person
screaming fire and brimstone.
Yeah,
no,
you're right on that.
And he's hilarious how people applied to every aspect of life,
even when they are not that flat out crazy,
but just a couple of degrees lower.
That desire for owning the through 10 for my philosophy is the Shemps in martial
arts is the same crop,
right?
It'd be for MMA before,
but it was slowly,
everybody was like,
Judah is the shit.
Fuck her at it doesn't you guys suck.
And it wasn't the same mentality that's organized it.
Or the John Savage,
the same mentality that I got the throat,
everybody else must be wrong.
Then I'm going to defend it against all evidence no matter what.
Yeah,
martial arts are very caught,
like a lot of the traditional martial arts and although I benefited a lot from
that,
I was definitely locked in.
It's just,
I was lucky that it was very positive and it was beneficial towards me,
but it was all bowing.
Every was sir.
You know,
you wear a special outfit when you walked into the place,
certain words you would use and you know there's like,
there's a lot of mind control to it.
It wasn't just discipline,
it was also like they were instilling a program in your mind and if you accepted
that program and make you more efficient fighter,
right,
make you more efficient,
killer,
make you more disciplined.
And that's the beauty of a MMA is when everybody was claiming this stuff.
If the,
you know,
they went with,
they built to call it in so many ways,
you know any 30 shirt on martial arts to be able to call it in terms of cult of
personality and a wise master,
who knows.
Avidly seeing,
I know all these rules are designed to increase the sense of Hyatt Iraqi
sometime and it seems like UFC,
he's like well prove it,
which is almost blasphemers if you say it and more 30 Chanel call and text where
you are not saying it,
that's a challenge or not telling somebody to fuck off by your saying Amen.
That sounds like a cool tod.
Show me.
Show me that he walks on their pressure under the real pressure,
the actual fight that's as close to emulating an actual fight is you can get
yeah.
And that stuff in Moss 30 shouldn't allow elements.
Liking Monster Legions is blast for me to say that you're questioning to master
you are doing
question is the healthiest thing,
man.
It's like I'm giving him a chance to prove it.
That doesn't work anymore.
That's that whole idea that you can't question that that's out.
That one's out.
That's done.
Anybody tells you not to question question that guy.
Right?
Because that's a mess.
Yup.
Oh,
who the fuck are you that you can't be questioned?
Are you an alien from another planet right now?
Either perfect being,
are you doctor Manhattan,
right?
No.
Right.
No,
you're not.
You're silly bitch.
And that's exactly where I was going with the new book that I,
the new book is called create your own religion.
And uh,
um,
what is it on what a publishing company
is a subset of ways.
Everybody.
Yes.
Yeah.
This info.com I have the pulse of the original disinfect books and that,
you know,
you're being lied to.
That's a great book.
Love ever.
That's a,
that's about some stuff.
You read that book and you're like,
what the fuck?
That was like sort of almost pre internet,
you know?
I mean it was,
it was a part of the Internet movement,
but having that book around it was like if you went over someone's house and you
saw that you were being lied to you,
like all right man,
like me brother.
Yeah.
You know how the man has been lying to you as well,
Danny.
Yeah.
Liberal La.
Um,
so create your own religion is what is the concept behind it is just to add all
the best parts to all the different ideologies that you've ever found and just
sort of Bruce Lee at all.
That's exactly what it takes.
These d I May may approach to the leader on it.
Watch the way I may may Stein's through 30 for not martial arts.
It's like these approaches,
what's tends to regular religions,
which is not,
not all the good stuff come from the same place.
You need to look at multiple places.
You need to test it.
You need to see what works,
what doesn't.
And the radar,
I'm being like,
Christianity sucks.
Or it's like,
it's like,
try it.
Try some seeings,
maybe 80% of feet.
You think these crazy bullshit that make no sense,
but you find a couple of times that you can help you in life.
Then use them.
Why not?
It doesn't mean I'm marrying the ideology,
but I'm going to take whatever I can use to make like to me,
the only thing that met their cs,
elevating the quality of life.
If you're elevating the quality of life,
I don't give a fuck where you've got the source things for formation from.
That's not what it's about is where it's leading.
Uh,
what kind of results does it create?
That's what interests me,
which is exactly the MMA mentalities.
It doesn't matter whether it technique is judo or karate or boxing or whatever
the fuck if he works,
he works.
Yeah.
That's one of the things about human beings ultimately is that we need someone
to lead by example.
You know,
you can't just get up and tell us how to do things.
You can't just get up and tell us.
That's why people,
especially in especially should be really distrusting of politicians.
In 2013 you should,
the way human beings should talk should be explaining what they've learned from
their own experiences.
It should not be telling people what they should do.
Exactly.
It should be learning from your own experiences telling you.
And if you don't have any experiences,
if you don't have any really unique experiences are really unique thoughts and
experiences,
why the fuck would you think that you should be able to lead?
But you're,
you're trying to lead because you're saying the words the right way and you're
saying the things that the polls say that people want to hear.
But as far as like unique individual thoughts like this shit,
like I have a dream,
but you could hear today and you go,
that motherfucker just nailed it and he just nailed it.
Martin Luther King nailed it.
Or Kennedy's speech about secret societies,
you know,
or any of his speeches he has of a bunch of brilliant speeches where the guy
just,
it made sense.
You're,
you're dealing with a unique
individual.
You're dealing with a person with great intelligence and yet you're dealing with
a person that you should be paying attention to.
And those people [inaudible] they are both colicky and humble at the same time.
Cause you know there's a certain caulking and Salah Bruce Lida comes from,
you are a bad motherfucker and you have noise because you to be,
it seems that no one else is doing,
but at the same time you'll know your limits reality while you'll see all the
times when stuff that you do and say it doesn't work.
It boils down to being honest with oneself,
which means knee Derek pumping yourself up or faking the modesty because you're,
it's like this is how it is.
This is the stuff that I do.
Well.
This is the stuff where I,
my Expedia on stops right there and I don't know anything beyond that or,
and even experience people got into this trip of like making perfect sense of
it,
right?
This is the event and I'm going to derive 12 lessons from it.
And it's like sometimes you can,
sometime he's just like,
that's my experience and he's fucking mind blowing.
And I don't know exactly what to make of it.
And that's how honest,
Ya know,
it's like looking at what since that happened at radio [inaudible] with deet
beyond what Experian warrants that you just our knowledge what happened,
you are knowledge,
what you derive from it and keep an open mind.
The fact that there's probably more to it now your idea about this book is this
just to pick out all the cool shit that you've learned,
all that cool shit that you've found and you're studying and have you studied
religion for health for a bunch?
And um,
to me it's like,
at the end of the day it doesn't matter what I'm teaching.
I always end up talking about the same stuff whether I'm talking about,
I start from American India and he stole your religion or martial arts.
I ended up talking about the same things because they are the stuff that life is
made of.
Uh,
the coolest Olympics,
sex,
gender,
rose.
Talk about sex and gender roles.
Yeah.
All good stuff.
Is there a way to the throat,
is there multiple where it's like Ed,
the relationship with death and dying?
I do a deal with that I would do you deal with the physical world with your own
body?
I mean the big topics are always the same.
They don't change the SBC fee kicks samples that you get there from may differ.
So to me,
I pick like a chapter each on some of the big things for me to seeing steady my
mind,
any human being need to find a need to decide where they stand on some of these
issues.
And I look at what's out there.
Some answers make no sense to me and they seem to lead down really on a healthy
path.
So thank you.
But no thanks.
Other answers make more sense or maybe they don't and I come up with my own,
but he's basic.
It really is boiled down to the Bruce Lee,
you know,
research your own experience,
uh,
reject what is,
he was less absorb what is useful and what's specific a year on,
you know,
his basic methodology for how to approach knowledge.
I mean he applied it to martial arts,
but really say but alien way of approach.
Just any kind of knowledge,
whether it's really,
it's about life and yeah,
it's hard for people to accept that.
Right?
So it's much easier to follow the pattern that your family's fouled.
I'm a Lutheran because of grandma's Lutheran.
Right.
GRANDPA always said that no matter what,
we'll be Lutherans.
Yep.
I remember talking to his girl and,
uh,
she said that she was going to get a tattoo of a cross.
And I said,
uh,
I said,
oh,
I go,
you really religious?
She goes,
well,
not really,
but you know what?
I was born Catholic and I figured that no matter what,
that's the one thing that'll be for the rest of my life,
the fuck.
I mean,
and I remember saying,
and I'm like,
you know,
I didn't know her very well,
so I was like,
okay,
um,
how do you know?
Like,
how do you know you won't change your mind about that?
And she's like,
oh my God,
my family would kill me.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
Well good luck with that.
Good luck with that.
Wow.
Is that he had at World War Two gun different,
they would be people.
Today's like,
no,
I'm not really nadZ ,
but you know,
if I don't put the shots stick on my grandma would her feeding so we'll get
really hard.
And so it's,
I don't hate the Jews,
but grandma fucking hates Jews.
I love grandma.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know it's like I don't want to make them sad.
You know what's hilarious is that she was going to get a Catholic tattoo in the
first place because like in the Bible it very specifically says
so like getting a religious tattoo.
It's like,
well you're not listening to me.
Yeah,
no,
only I listened when it's convenient,
but across tattoo is so sexy.
It makes me look spiritual and it thins out my back.
And that's the other point of like the people who got pissed when you are
cutting eight year old,
he's like,
what do you mean create your own?
It's not,
there are some absolute truths that full from heaven.
They stop those people.
People that are making up their own shit anyway.
I mean when people say they little Sam thing is bullshit Israeli,
they are making up their own thing cause the wheel 80 to some parts of that they
don't like,
they will focus on the parts daylight and pretend that it's the one and all the
interpretation if you're going to do that,
might as well be honest and just peek from any source if you are going to be
continuous.
I think that religion in general in the future is much more likely to be studied
and lets less likely to be practice.
Right.
Cause I think in especially in like a really hardcore fundamentalist form,
yeah,
it's much less likely that people are going to accept that as time goes on and
information gets distributed broader and faster.
But then again people will always be afraid of dying.
He voted.
We'd always be afraid of uh,
where do you know,
where do we come from?
Is there any meaning in the universe?
And pure rationality doesn't give you a very satisfactory answers.
No,
it does not.
So when you want answers and you can get them through rezoning that case,
it's like well fuck reason.
Then just give me any answer cause I can deal with not having salmon living that
way.
I need some solid basis.
I just have a whole bit about that.
Is that a,
I would really like to join the call.
If anybody could fucking write one that doesn't make me throw up when I write
it.
Just one of you guys.
It's not like a smart guy out there that can write like some much more
believable shit.
Then Scientology or Mormonism or
any of the newcomers,
you know like those are the,
the the law,
the two latest,
greatest new commerce.
It really stuck Mormonism and Scientology and they're both fucking cuckoo for
cocoa puffs.
You read both of them.
They're hilarious.
There's laminates and shit.
They both have extra planets to both at planets where they know some shit's
going down.
Both of them.
Scientology and Mormonism,
like cold lob,
right.
Isn't that the Mormon planet started or some re
Marvin story is the how 1970s most Mormons believe that direct skiing is a sign
that God hates your guts.
Basically.
That is a wow.
But you know,
[inaudible] 1930s that was fairly mainstream view.
I wonder what made them change their mind exactly.
The 1970 suddenly God sent a memo saying,
wait,
you guys got it wrong?
Dark skin is totally cool.
I have nothing against it.
You just made a mistake.
He's like the civil rights movement managed to convince not just millions of
Americans but God himself that racism is no longer cool.
Yeah.
God didn't understand until he saw Martin Luther King give a speech.
That's how strong that I have a dream speeches.
That's what I do.
Read the whole law three times.
The teats divinely revealed the falls from the sky one day.
It's so funny cause people when it doesn't make sense anymore,
we'll change it cause it's like I can't really go around saying this shit
anymore.
It doesn't.
So where we got it wrong,
God,
Mandy's other way.
Really all along every spring we've been seeing for the last time there,
DRC,
just a measly interpret.
You know we miss interpreted thing is God was right.
We were all of course,
woops.
Woopsies isn't that like,
um,
what,
when
Martin Luther translated the Bible to a phonetic form and then the people
started interpreting it and then like going,
well,
how come no one's practicing any of this shit?
How come you guys are all,
well,
why the fuck do you have so much money?
What's going on?
Why are we peasants forever?
It doesn't say that here.
Like this is,
you guys made this shit up.
Like you made all this shit up about being a peasant and ordained a peasant
forever,
but then you'll be rewarded for your toils and heaven that's not in here.
Definitely.
This isn't saying here.
You're a peasant for life.
That's the part that I have always the most fun in regards to people making up
their own stuff.
To me.
We could stay on it.
He's like,
you want to be Christian?
Hey,
there's good stuff.
Hold for it.
But then our you capitalist at the same time,
because there are so many passages where they are so hardcore.
I mean you have the,
the Jesus,
uh,
it's easier for a camel to go through the eye of a needle than for a rich man to
get into heaven,
which is like something that Jesus said that which Damn Jesus,
that Shit's deep.
Kyron Marx would blush.
You know what I mean?
He's like fucking bad.
That fire and that shows up over and over again.
A bunch of passages that are anti cumulation of wild and says like,
so you're going to be a Christian but you're going to be hardcore capitalist.
He's like,
yeah,
cause I'm done with Jesus.
That part about money.
I would just skip over those spots.
So just an focus on some weird
interpretational one passage that may seem to say seem that he say something
else and I'm going to ignore the other 19 where he's clearly state in fuck
accumulation of wealth.
Yeah.
That was the other thing that they had found in the translations was that Jesus
hung out with people like them.
Yup.
Jesus hung out with the poor and the downtrodden and the prostitutes and that's
who Jesus was palling around with.
Like,
what the fuck have you guys been teaching us?
And so the people that wanted to go even further than Martin Luther,
these,
uh,
Anabaptists,
I guess,
is that anarchy baptist?
Is that a combination of,
is that baptism for a second time?
Because they rejected the infant baptism cause they said the baby doesn't tie a
fucking choice.
It needs to be an adult choice.
So they would have baptizers and adult when you want to write.
And then the third baptism was when they drowned you,
they catch you,
right.
If they catch shooed and uh,
either you did or Lutheran swore Catholics,
if they would catch you,
then they would decide it was their way of being funny was to drown you cncs.
Oh,
you would like to baptism.
We'll give you a third one.
And,
and about,
you know,
Anabaptism Anabaptist thinking that just,
that does sound like an anarchistic,
you know,
and uh,
and they were,
they were really radical,
Huh?
They were there wanted no private property.
They wanted free education,
free healthcare,
those damn communists.
Well,
meanwhile,
why is that bad?
Right?
You know,
this is what drives me crazy.
It's not that I don't think that people should be able to have land.
I definitely think that you should be able to have land.
But why is it so bad to like say that you shouldn't,
right?
Like why is everybody so committed to hanging onto it?
Cause like what?
What?
Let's let's hear this out.
Okay.
What if we don't have land?
Let's have it this way.
What if the world consists of Jamie,
Brian,
you and me?
Okay.
We're the only four people in my world and it has no,
no one,
no one left.
Okay.
But the good news is we're on Catalina island and that's all there is.
Um,
can we just share what the fuck?
I'll put my house over here.
You put your house over there.
I'll say hi in the morning.
We got a house on this spot of dirt that gets problematic when you get into the
300 million people range.
That's the fucking problem.
Yeah.
The problem is it's too God damn many of us and everybody would want a house
right by the lake,
by the lake is too many of us do.
You can't have a house by the lake.
Right.
But come on,
man.
Well,
we were here first.
So listen,
this is our land now.
We have a house by lake man.
That's fucked up.
This is our world.
We're all in this together.
It is all in this together.
But I was born in 1947 and I've had this house by the leg and I'm not giving up
my fucking house by the lake.
Right?
What?
Can I use your house by the lake?
No,
you can't bitch.
I'll shoot you
this.
Too many of us,
and there's not enough cool spot.
Right.
That's the real fucking problem.
Yeah.
That's not private property.
Right,
because really,
it'd be perfect if we all,
you know,
if we all had the use of everything,
that would be amazing.
You
don't have,
it's not my laptop or my table.
It's the table.
It's the laptop because their laptop I can use.
Yeah,
you can use that laptop.
You know?
It's like if that would be beautiful,
if that,
if that worked.
Right.
Exactly.
In utopia land and utopia.
It's idea that you know that he's the way you,
you want to look Topia land.
Yeah.
That's one of the things that I uh,
that I've always wondered like it,
we'll,
will we see a utopia?
Well we see,
uh,
like a working utopia in our time,
a working community where no one's or can't call me Ott.
I buy it on a more scale,
but it would have to start as a community and it would have to,
the best you could do I think is probably a couple of thousand people.
Yeah.
Word started getting wacky.
And you would have to like have meetings and everybody would have to really talk
about let's make sure we avoid all the pitfalls that I fell in all societies
before us.
Yeah.
It's serious.
That's some serious end of the world type shit though.
That's the only way that would ever happen.
Right.
And I guess today there's a better way to go about it.
Cause.
Whereas in the past,
if you do that,
you,
you know,
you ran off into the mountains,
create your one movie where all of the other bus starts skin.
Today you can have an element of where you have your out community at the same
time you're in connected to or why they're wired in a way that doesn't isolate
you.
It doesn't make you weird and the and of you off from everything else because
that was always the downside of the small community.
Danieli bold la Party pooper.
That's what I just heard about your statement
called the perfectly okay.
I was just kidding.
That's out for the mountains.
That's what I'm saying.
That's the way it,
dude.
Let's do it on elk with spears and shit.
Nobody could say a word.
Start our own families.
You that you don't want to separate from society.
Society is pretty fucking awesome.
It's just we need to figure out a way to fix society in and lessen the amount of
shitty people,
shitty products,
the,
our product of creating human beings.
We need to figure out a way to make less of those guys in Cleveland,
that kidnap girls and keeping locked in their basement for 10 years.
Yup.
That's,
that should be like our number one priority,
not curing lack of boners,
right?
Yeah.
Not arresting people for funding,
selling boner pills at seven 11 either Brian or do you do about that?
They need to cut it.
They came in and they busted all of those and it was exactly as Aubrey had said,
Aubrey told us that with the reason why those dick pills work is because they're
filling up with Cialis and Viagra and shit.
Right.
It's exactly what it was.
It was all Cyan Sawyer.
Okay.
So it wasn't,
and it sucks because it's getting harder to find the good ones.
Now we see a prescription for Cialis cause I don't really need it.
It's just fun to be,
you can get it.
You don't need it.
Get it.
Yeah.
You can get one you,
you say,
hey my Dick's not working that good.
There's a lot of unscrupulous doctors.
They would write you off a prescription.
Then when you don't have to fuck around with something,
you don't even know what it is.
If you take a Viagra,
you know that's a Viagra.
So you're going crazy.
You're playing Russian roulette with your help,
but seven 11 fucking
stuff that looks like pop rocks.
You throw it into your,
your drink and shaking it up.
This is a real sex enhancer.
Meanwhile,
it's like seven times the normal level of Cialis you're supposed to take and
you're gonna Break Your Dick one day.
You're gonna get that priapism to drain your Dick with a needle.
It's funny is the the one that's the Cialis one,
uh,
the pills have gotten bigger on some of them and it says,
now it says like last up to seven days.
And then on the back it says,
only take one every 24 hours.
So I've taken like three of this seven,
seven day ones.
Which ones like ours,
we know every,
I take it three in a week,
but that's a week's worth of bone or so that's like 49 boners and one boner.
You should not do that.
You're going to break your Dick,
you Dixon going to work without them.
That's what's going to happen.
And you're gonna,
you're gonna also confidence wise,
you're going to rely on that wonder Dick.
Well,
I can tell I go,
how am I going to fuck a girl with my regular dick?
My regular deck just doesn't get that hard.
But when I get,
when I'm on wonder Dick,
I mean I masturbate every day though.
So I would know immediately.
You're on every day.
You're constantly masturbating.
No,
I'm going to take Mexican Bay while you're on Viagara I take breaks.
Oh good.
But you cycle on and off.
I took one on stage,
uh,
in Sacramento because I had one on me.
It was called gold roller and it's as gold gorilla on the front.
And uh,
and I was showing everybody and someone's like,
hey,
good.
I'm like,
all right,
I'll take it.
I open it up and I put it in my mouth and at [inaudible] at excellent breaks in
my mouth.
You know how like the capsule,
it was this boner,
like,
cause I couldn't,
I couldn't talk because it was so much powder.
It just exploded and it was the most disgusting thing ever.
But then I had like a crazy boner for like three days,
three days
that they're still killing rhinos to look to give Chinese dudes boners do they
not know about the boner pills?
Do they not know about Viagara?
Is that possible?
What's that Horny goat seed all about?
Like killed
Horny goat weed?
I don't know.
I don't even,
I think that's a mood enhancer.
Yeah.
Let me,
let's go with that.
I'm going to read that.
Uh,
I've never taken the horny goat weed in any mass quantities.
Maybe not taking it on once or twice as a,
uh,
an ingredient and something else,
right?
Yeah.
They'd been knocking them down a lot lately though.
There's been at least 10 different companies that have been hit by that a you
thing where they made them pull the pills because there was Viagara in them.
And so what is it trademark infringement or something?
No,
they're,
they're selling prescription drugs and mixed with like apples.
You know,
Erin's still gotcha.
Yeah.
And calling just a supplement.
It's called the epimedium.
Hmm?
Where do you go with what we do is,
yeah,
it's called e.
P.
I.
N.
E.
Medium medium.
Um,
and uh,
it's also known as barren ward.
Bishop's hat,
fairy wings,
horny goat weed,
rowdy lamb,
herbs,
Randy beef grass.
It's all about like Boehner ethics stuff.
Yeah.
He said,
well,
gosh,
it's a genesis of 60 or more species of flowering plants and the family of
Berber who I don't even know how to say that.
Berber
does a hard one.
Well,
let's try this.
Brilliant.
Richer Berbee Berber.
It does say,
says a large majority of our endemic to southern China.
Uh,
Bubba,
bubba.
What is it supposed to do?
APHRODISIAC,
Bam son.
Let's hear what Brian does.
Many species,
the qualities associated with a content of I Caryn.
According to legend,
this property was discovered by a Chinese,
got a goat herder who noticed the sexual activity in his flock scene.
Same story as the fucking,
uh,
the quarter subs.
Mushrooms.
It's probably a bullshit story.
Probably some marketing shit from the 1400 balls with the mushroom man.
With this horny goat weed.
I even know the girl,
that mushroom stuff does fucking work.
I hadn't mixed.
Does he mind mind when you are telling me earlier?
Um,
but I and about hey,
why are you taking those pills?
You don't know what's in.
I was picturing your early story about the Zombie ions and I was imagining like
that mushroom going into the peel that I takes and these dick exploding.
Oh yeah.
It can be
a little body dies and his dick becomes like a fireworks display.
A lot of these supplements that you take these buttons poses are actually ants.
Tons of Africans.
It's African black ants.
Yeah.
We've talked about this before in the podcast where the boner pills.
Yeah,
a lot of them.
Cause if you just type in boner pill and you don't have a bunch of stuff where
we did talk about that,
but I think we got sidetracked and never came to a rational conclusion.
Yeah.
Cause I think it was one of those,
one of the pills he actually,
that was pulled by whatever the FDA,
uh,
last week was even called something like Boehner answer something like this is,
I'll,
I'll give you the rundown.
Scientifically,
if anybody gives a shit,
it actually apparently does have a similar effect to nitric oxide.
A supplements which also give you boners,
which is also one of the reasons why Viagra is a performance enhancing
supplement.
Um,
a lot of athletes,
I think it's banned from the Olympics.
I think you can't use a viagara anymore because it,
it gives you a boost,
uh,
an athletic boost.
I think it's an endurance boost.
The same thing it does when it gives your dick this crazy fucking right under
deck.
It also does that for the rest of your body.
It increases blood flow or something.
They didn't know that.
Yeah.
You're recycling your blood in more parts of your body.
Some around what he said,
but with some science,
none of us really know.
She's putting all
this stuff.
Uh,
[inaudible],
uh,
sill den Nafld Sildenafil.
That's a by Agra,
that's Viagara sill sold an apple.
I'm probably,
I'm probably butchering it but it's s.
and that's what's called that Viagara.
this stuff that it produces called I,
Karen,
the active compound epidemia inhibits at epimedium rather inhibits the activity
of PDE five.
And so what this PDE five shit is a,
it works the same with Horny goat weed.
The inhibit in inhibiting it as it does with Viagara.
So it probably would work,
but it probably wouldn't work as good because I think that Viagara shit is like
nuclear.
I think they've got to tell like this is like,
I think my next
a little harder,
but you take a Viagra and your dick just fucking gets like body slammed against
your zippers.
Like where are we partying?
You Dick is just really rowdy.
Noxious.
You can find realistic,
you can feel your heartbeat on the very bottom of it.
I love that.
And your heartbeat on the Bun me deck.
Yeah.
Like that pain.
It goes down the bottom.
Yeah.
And don't measure your heart rate then.
Cause that's not your resting heart rate.
You're not resting right there.
Your Dick is going crazy or ticks turn into a Zombie.
Yeah.
Even like old dudes that are like barely alive.
They can take a couple of,
I aggers stick a finger up their ass.
Damn it.
It's so fun going to massage parlors.
Eric can't stop it.
You do it on purpose.
You're just pretending you're the super freak.
I'm just a super freak.
I don't even know what's up.
I'm trying not to think about sex,
but just having you in the room,
I'm starting to think I'm on 7,000 milligrams of some seventh of that funnel.
Sell different of an owl or whatever the fuck this stuff that's called and
starting to think that in the seventies I would have a raincoat,
you know?
Oh you probably would.
Well if you didn't have a podcast,
you'd have a raincoat.
How about that?
You fuck now I've just turned into this.
Well the problem is it's more fun than not doing it.
Why you're liking it.
I can do it.
People are like,
why would he like to have hard ons go to massage parlors?
Jerked off.
Hmm.
Why?
Why wouldn't he
jerking off?
I'm just looking at it.
That was,
I added that for comic relief.
Of course.
I'm just displaying my boner for this poor girl.
Added that in four s to lighten up the moment so it doesn't seem as much like
sexual assault.
Right.
This one girl had a tan line from the rope the other day.
It was a rope.
What do you mean what?
What rope?
When she was carried into this country,
I think in San Francisco,
those are fresh son of a bear.
So for us like fuck.
I was like dear.
She had a watch and she went tanning and she took off her watch or that's from
rope.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
All right.
And we want to talk about it too much of a,
it's a scary subject.
Well that website that are always talking about that I feel like I shouldn't
talk about it.
Talk about it.
You shouldn't get that.
What's always going to get taken away and you're going to get monitored by the
government because there was a bone of police out there and they don't like
people getting their boners taking care of any illegal manners.
That's what's going on.
And that's some of the lamest ways to spend dollars of all time
stopping dudes from getting jerked off at like handy massage parlors.
You might really sucks that shit.
Oh,
sorry.
Go ahead.
No,
no,
go.
We have undercover sting operations.
Well,
I went in there at 3:00 PM with my boner.
I took boner pills just to be sure.
I told her I want a full service.
She said,
Howard,
I tapped her leg twice.
She grabbed my cock and I threw on the ground.
I think there's two things I wouldn't mind getting arrested for.
Warren is,
uh,
having weed on me or selling or smoking weed or prostitution.
I don't,
I like both of those.
Who Cares?
Like what?
Oh,
you like to fuck.
And you're like,
wait,
who cares?
Well,
officer,
when I threw her to the ground and make the arrest,
I came all over her face completely coincidentally.
Oh can I say I'm a red blooded American man?
The Fed up through institution is still illegal in 49 and the NAF states in new
assets.
I fucking insane.
I mean it seems like a mistake.
It seems like a mistake to tell people that they can fuck people as much as they
like,
but they can't get paid for it.
But you can marry a guy that you don't really love and you can fuck him and then
you could divorce him and make money off of it.
And then they'll write songs about you.
Right.
That's okay.
You're allowed to be a gold digger,
but she can't be a whore.
That is fucking fascinating.
And you're not even allowed to be a gold digger because women will like look at
that bench.
You know she doesn't love him.
He's fucking oldest shit.
I think she is 40 years younger than him.
What the fuck they have in common?
It's prostitution.
What does it have in common?
She came from Thailand.
He's got $1 billion.
Correct.
Shut your hall.
You know exactly what it is.
Let it happen.
Yeah,
I mean adults.
How's it look?
How's it affected you?
Fuck,
exactly.
It's domain is like you're not hurting anybody else.
As long as there's no,
nobody's forced.
There's no one that age shit.
There's none of that.
There's no incentive at all.
It's back the fuck off.
Let people leave out.
They want,
yeah.
Who Cares?
And there's,
you know,
there's a,
there's an argument that there's nothing wrong with sex.
So why should there be anything wrong with paying for a sox?
Yep.
And the reason why it seems like such a terrible thing to us now is that it's
frowned upon.
It's looked down upon.
But if you look at what it actually is like,
it's just sex.
Like it's,
it's weird to a massage people,
right?
You got to pay someone to massage you.
So you go to a place where they guarantee everybody wants to fuck.
Okay,
guys want to fuck girls want to fuck.
That makes sense to me.
But nobody wants to give you a fucking massage.
Okay.
They may not want to give you a goddamn massage.
Girls don't want to give them,
they would do it for a little while to do,
to feel love.
You right.
You know,
I'll give them such someone I love,
but the reality is I don't want to do it shits a lot of work,
but sex is not a lot of work,
but yet you can pay for the massage and he can't pay for sex.
That is purely puritan values cause it is essentially the same thing.
But 90% of us will never get paid to massage someone and 90% of us will never
get paid to have sex with someone.
I those numbers
I fucking made up.
I'm,
I'm doing the math here helped me.
Um,
but,
but the reality is they're the same goddamn thing.
It's the same goddamn thing.
Absolutely.
I agree.
It should be your choice,
right?
If you fucking skeeved out by feet and you go to massage people,
but you don't mind giving head,
that's you.
That's you man.
So do it.
But it's okay.
And to me it's more on us than a,
you know,
a lot of people then flashlights,
how about that?
We've had those for two fucking years.
It's way more honest to pay a person to do it and you know,
line and hooking up just really cause you want to fuck somebody.
Hello.
Flashlights are very good for that.
That's very,
oh and by the way,
people have been emailing me 1700 times saying tell Joe to catch a flashlight.
He still has so many scars.
I'm sure it probably preferably slight.
You wanted one.
Will you shut an emailed me before I got here?
I still haven't seen it in the closet.
I ate them,
I fed them to my chickens.
Right.
Number.
The thing is like the stuff you were saying about how people perceive the sexes
are really not okay in some ways.
And there's this pubic done vibe.
Mostly American though,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's where my weird uh,
fall beach scene coming.
Cause when I came to us and that was just trying to ask,
you know,
are learning new language or picking up new awards.
And so I heard the word does a lot.
I'm like slapped.
What the fuck doesn't mean.
It's like,
wow.
The woman was a kind of screaming until the [inaudible] left that Rye,
blah,
and I was like,
well,
if sex is a good thing,
then as lot somebody will freely give sex away in disagreement as to the left or
right.
It's kind of like a humanitarian.
I'm like,
he's like,
if philanthropists do some sort of sexual matter theories,
that's a beautiful thing.
Right?
He always really,
really bad.
I was like,
wait,
why don't let me try it again?
You know?
It's like that.
That shit doesn't make sense to,
wasn't there a woman in Italy that made it to the parliament?
Oh yeah.
Porn Star.
She truly not.
Yes.
What a great name for a dirty bitch.
She Shalina.
That's Eataly for you.
All right.
Pardon?
Stire actually,
I've been multiple times that she was the first and then a few others.
Then the same thing and they all got elected because he's like,
he that he's like,
I'm going to vote for these annoying old guy or diesel noidal guy.
Hey,
there's the Barnstar,
but ain't no seriously
the place up north.
They went with a tan line girl,
I think it was.
It was a GI GFE place,
which is the girlfriend experiment or experience.
And uh,
it sucked because when she was talking like she didn't want to massage me at
all.
So you just said it was kind of just like crawling on me,
like tapping me was like bullshit.
But then at the end of it,
she just wanted to lay down next to me.
So we were both like laying down and then she fell asleep and it was so sad.
Like I'm like,
all right,
I'm just going to stay here for a bit.
I guess she's sleeping.
I'm like,
that's going to happen.
And then like a door slams,
I don't know if like somebody else was coming in or if it was like the mme one,
what the fuck,
you know?
And she'd get like,
gets up real quick and quick.
Oh,
oh,
thank you.
I'll be right back with tea.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
this poor girl just fell asleep on me.
That's so sad.
It's the saddest thing in the world.
Ah,
she probably
blacked out from shame
from trying to deal with this.
Viagara induce the,
the range is three and a half hours.
It's probably just shock when you corner a little mouse,
scream at it freezes horny goat weed.
That painting Horny goat weed.
Fainting.
Horny goat
is a,
it's a weird,
weird aspect that we have.
This thing were weirded out about sex,
but that's how this country got started,
was started by puritans.
People forget that.
Did the echoes of the,
the retards that fucking founded this place,
there's still,
they're still here.
They were religious fanatics.
The pewter turns left.
You hear about this stuff about the Punic.
Don's coming here for religious freedom.
It's total bullshit.
They didn't come here for religious freedom.
He means they came here for the footy not to be persecuted.
It's a whole different game.
Doesn't mean we don't want to persecute somebody else.
We just don't want to be persecuted.
Not religious freedom means I don't work their own freedom.
It's like I don't like to be in that place.
I don't like my place in the game.
I have nothing against the game itself.
As long as I got to be on top and the start fucking native Americas piling them
up and stacking them and wack and does it right.
The guys who couldn't see there,
the church and needing gland as crazy liberals,
you know they are the hardcore fundamentalist of their data match like
fundamental is today.
Back then there was no Hollywood so they were pissed about the theater of
London.
They're like there's all the sacs and spectacle and decent that exactly the same
arguments that you hear today about a fundamental is to gain entertainment
industry.
Exactly the same thing cause into 1569 [inaudible] are we in the puritans?
It's amazing.
So what happened?
They came over first or they were one of the first to come over here.
Yeah,
no they were well no you're right cause it's the first day I designed their set
of events in Jamestown,
in Virginia and dined like 13 years later.
Not that long later they had a wine,
Plymouth rock and a famous one,
which is the Qa Donaldson don't off dot.
Then these are guys that England was more than happy to get rid off cause it's
like they are,
we are,
they are crazy.
They are knowing they are too much.
So please go.
Yeah go site to the new world.
That's a great idea.
These guys were ready to leave because they felt that they could start their own
society where pewter done value is with the rules.
Right.
And having to deal with more mellow vision stuff could astounding how much
different would America have turned out if people landed on the west coast
instead of the east coast throwback.
How much different would America have turned out of England was on the other
side of the world and then they came over and landed in La and we're like oh
shit.
Oh Shit bitches.
We ain't never going back.
There's no winter.
Right.
It doesn't happen.
Like they landed in fucking Massachusetts man that is with no heat.
Yup.
Oh my God.
No he no cars.
You have a few animals to oh Jesus,
you going to try to collect food and the four months that everything's not
frozen right now.
And it's funny cause when they first came they usually would,
the didn't really how to make a living here.
So they would fuck things up and within a year or two they would start treating
each other in this cheese.
You buy these stories and it's like some weird a sick shit though.
It was pure survival.
Yup.
No that happened in England too,
right?
Wasn't there.
They,
they,
they reconstructed a girl that they had a eaten and uh,
she was a 14 years old.
That was,
that was in,
that was in style.
That was Betty first.
I made a cut in the first versus a buddy teacher called on the customer to stay
and she was 14.
Yeah.
Cause you know they need stuff.
They Indian so they are not going to have much help from them.
They don't know how to make a living throughout the year in a new harsh
environments.
So soon enough you start eating your friends.
That's always a good idea.
It's fucking amazing that we've made it this far.
Yup.
See it as a person who knows as much as history,
but as a person who knows as much about history is you do does it,
it must be like really shocking when you know that this shit was just a couple
of years away.
You know,
that's the,
that to me is what's mind blowing.
The stuff that has be inclusive or normal throughout much of human history.
It blows your mind to think like probably 75% of people work totally cool with
with these ideas that today they would lamb the straightening like a psychiatric
hospital back then totally normal and again he buzzed down to the same thing.
These people too lazy to question what they are told and just going with the
program and just not really a,
why am I burning people at the stake because they believe in different idea.
It's what my grandpa did and she's cool so I must,
you know,
it's like not really stopping to think is these are already highly things.
These are good idea.
These out how I want to leave.
Okay.
How did people find out about the pilgrims,
whether or not they were doing good enough that people decided let's join these
crazy bitches.
How did all that happen?
Go back and forth and then we're telling how great it was,
sweet and each other.
That's fucking awesome.
There are now some people don't support money as an investment in days.
A lot of of these weren't just the random individuals coming in.
They were sponsored by corporations is an idea and the reasoning and fast men.
So these guys had the economic interested in keeping the thing going and there
are plenty of people who had a shitty life in England.
So even going into the crazy wild place across the word was back there and and
what they knew back in England and so they were willing to take chances.
I mean one of the things that people don't know a lot of the time or don't
emphasize enough is the idea that a huge chunk of people who came here were
basically slaves.
White people probably know him but he just didn't where indenture servants,
which technically meant you only serve for seven years,
but most of them are work so hard by their owners that they killed them before
the 70 [inaudible] were up.
So really if you were an indenture servants,
they are pretty much fucked because you are going to be in conditions that are
semis Lavery.
Um,
they are not going to survive to leave see the day when you are fried.
So it doesn't really matter whether it's in tod,
it only lasts so long cause you are never going to leave at that time.
So a lot of these guys would run off the second they arrive here.
They would try to show their best face when they show up at an Indian and
compliment saying,
hey man,
I mean nice guy.
Those guys are footie.
Can you please take me in?
And a bunch of tribes who take them in.
And so you would have these communities where some time you would have a lot of
British people.
We escape the settlement to go leave with Indians because otherwise they would
get work to that back into settlements and a,
it's a three story.
I know the colonies would pass these laws preventing anybody from leaving the
settlements and going to live with the Indians because otherwise your labor
force just left and now you have to work on your own.
How many white dudes went dancing with wolves style?
Quite a bit.
There's a,
there's a really cool story.
I remember,
I forget the guy's name right now,
but there was a back at the very beginning of the puritan days,
there was this one community of sort of crazy unconventional.
The guys that left the main puritan towns and started their own thing.
We eat a bunch of local Indians.
They would have,
they basically at the interracial community where they would buy her tail out.
They would bring cover their dances,
some of like sort of hippy heaven.
Except that because he was a little too hippy half and these guys didn't make
plans for the purest I wanting to kick their ass because they are community was
actually growing at a faster rate than the puritans.
More people wanted to live there,
but the puritan and military muscle and so they went to kick their ass and
squash them.
Does motherfucking puritans and that's us.
Yeah.
If those hippies had planned,
yeah,
fuck.
I mean I'm all for having fun,
but put two hours a day into planning that maybe you want to know what to do
when people start shooting at you crazy religious fucks it up dressed up like
Johnny Cash and they live right down the road.
Exactly what Kaiser Kooks.
They're cooks.
They're all just the same.
Okay,
listen,
we know their kooks.
Yup.
But listen,
they spend a lot of time praying that we need to spend that exact amount of time
making arrows.
That's the idea.
And instead of half piece stupid,
he'd be who don't make plans or crazy or religious fundamentalist two are well
armed and know how to use their guns.
It's like,
well,
not exactly the greatest alternatives,
but I mean why is it nicer than the other?
But it doesn't make any,
you know,
they can leave it in reality because they don't make blinds,
they don't set some stuff for when shit goes wrong.
And so the other guys who are way worse ween because they are more disciplined,
those motherfuckers,
so they absorbed them is the same over them.
They send them back,
you know,
some of them were killed,
the,
some of them are reabsorbed under close watch,
some of it,
you know,
bunch of options there.
But one of the weirdest things about history from me as I get older is realizing
how short a period of time that was a go where things were.
So bananas don't,
1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue 1492 yup.
That's hard to believe.
There was no buildings here.
Just that logo.
Especially when you look at England and the shit that's up in London meeting,
you can go visit things in London or a thousand years old America itself.
So only 200 fucking,
I know
someone,
he landed in The Bahamas,
you
know,
a little over 400 years ago.
Right.
That's crazy.
It is.
And in that sense,
yeah.
I leave living in Europe,
he's at 30 public was you go down the street to meet your friend and you Harvard
next to a building that's like 2000
fuck fuck.
It's crazy.
Really nuts to think that those people just live in that one spot forever.
Yup.
You know,
that's one of the really cool things.
This Dan Carlin thing on um,
on the history of the Mongols.
Oh it was realizing how much these guys affected Asia and,
and,
and how much they would have affective Europe and they affected Russia.
Yup.
Yeah.
Like Europe got really lucky there Susan or depending on point of view cause
yeah,
what they add wasn't exactly what they had was horrible.
The,
they,
they dodged a crazy bullet with,
with those motherfuckers did.
And then what the,
one of the craziest things that Dan Carlin was talking about was when they took
over Baghdad and killed everybody,
that it literally hasn't ever recovered.
No.
They say he was like see
send 30 years before the population was at the same level as before.
They wiped out.
I mean the Mongols,
he didn't fuck around.
Yeah.
They really were genocide one oh one you know,
as they,
yeah.
Those guys and deeply progress,
they ruined cultures.
They rule everything they learned.
Yep.
See Ya.
Light it on fire.
They didn't want to take it with them.
Nope.
It's a,
if it's not useful in a [inaudible] or running around with my horses down the
fuck,
do I care?
That's the nuttiest thing is that they never really,
they caught,
captured all these cities,
but they,
they live were no mats.
Yeah.
They didn't have a country.
Huge mass of people making their way across the world.
Killing everybody.
Yep.
My favorite on that one is when the,
um,
when they do enter bag,
that and the whole story,
there was the thing of this one guy,
he was a locale governor or Keel,
the Mongol traders early on.
So the Mongols were piece,
they sent an ambassador or this guy chopped off the head of the ambassadors to
saying they are spies.
He banked on the fact that it was a big desert separating you from the bone goes
so they wouldn't be able to invade.
He didn't make his calculations right.
Cause the Mongols go out through the desert.
They show up at his door and after mass wiping out with everyone else,
they grab this guy and said,
you are a greedy motherfuckers because of that.
You want gold,
we'll give you all the gold you want.
They mailed a bunch of gold and pour molten gold down his throat to kill him.
Does guys into his eyes and his ears as well.
Those guys are not playing around and then they probably chopped its head open
and get that gold back.
Exactly.
It's like,
okay now,
sorry.
No,
we need to be back.
If you don't mind that.
It's just amazing that that again,
1200 B a d 1200 that's not that long ago.
This none of this is that long ago.
And that was the a couple of hundred years before Martin Luther,
you know,
and that's just a few hundred years before people came to America and that's a
few hundred years for slavery.
Was abolished and it's all,
it is so recent.
It's really weird.
So I mean,
right?
Yeah.
Deer in California where we stand back in the 1850s more than half of the
American Indian populations,
I feel like 80% what was wiped out would not be cause of diseases and not
because of stuff,
but what they adding then a lot of California towns,
whoever they Indian hands,
which was the law cowl on the lockout newspaper,
they would publish the scene that if you,
you know,
you're broke,
you have no money,
go kill some Indian scalp them.
And if you come back into town,
the local government will pay you a certain amount for the scalp of an adult.
Male Alito,
they last for the scalpel for an adult female and a little bit less for the
scalp of a child because it's good for the health of the community to wipe out
Indians.
1850s not immediately on years ago.
Right.
You know,
under our feet.
That's a three.
Wow.
Yup.
You know,
I always wondered what that whole scalping thing,
where that came from.
I thought it was the Indians did the scalping,
you know,
actually they do stuff like that in it,
but they did it sit on the ward because they ain't got died of some to just
carry around people's heads to prove that you kill them.
So it's like,
do I really have to carry these big fucking thing?
Could imagine like chopping off the head of somebody like Tito Ortiz.
Big giant head.
It's like I have to carry around to put up with at Ikea they can,
I just scalping be diluted.
So [inaudible] a bunch of places so then you know you could scalp to butt cheeks
and say,
ah,
I killed a couple of Baldrige too.
I mean you get three for the price of one if you were unscrupulous.
Yeah.
This motherfuckers scalping balled in yet.
That's one of the beautiful things about the native Americans.
They actually go bald.
Right?
There wasn't a one of their genetics that genetic pastor sort of only got
introduced to them after we came around.
I tell you these Indians shirt smell though.
That's about it.
Nevermind.
No Butt.
Cheeks don't smell that bad.
Back then.
This was back then,
the whole package,
right.
Everything below the pallet was just a mess up the east coast.
They probably never really painted their face.
It was just from butts
in a sense on how they use it to go.
It's there bad.
I seen that they will do where a lot of uh,
Indian tribes,
they are,
they would shave every other part of their head,
but they would leave these really long strand of fair in the middle.
That was like the Scallop,
not that you leave it out there for others as a challenge to other warriors of
saying,
Hey,
it is my scalp.
You want to take it to come and take it.
It makes it even easier for you to grasp it and pull it out.
Yeah,
so he was a,
he's one.
That's what you kind of thing.
He's like,
I'll leave it on you.
Leave your son.
Let's see what gets to take home was first.
That's ridiculous.
That's just begging for the gun to be invented.
Silly pitches out there shooting pointed rocks at each other.
The fuck are you doing man,
grabbing each other's hair,
cutting each other's heads off.
See that guy that on that video the other day that was like walking across I
think like two like a waterfall or something and he was doing like the balancing
thing and he fell and he held on and then he was like trying to climb across it
and he had a long ponytail in his pony tail.
Got Stuck in it and he let go and he scalped himself dies
is a son who died from that.
Yeah.
Cause he,
cause he fell.
Oh my God,
his ponytail stayed on the line.
Uh,
that's when you know,
that can be good.
That's a shit choice.
And hair were either death or God hates you.
Yeah.
You fucked up son.
You definitely fucked up.
There was a woman in France recently who died.
She fell like 900 feet toward death off a cliff.
And by the time they got to where the vultures that are already eating there,
there was nothing left.
But bones,
she is also how you know you fucked up.
Yeah.
First of all,
if you're in a place where they're not killing the vultures have,
but it's like,
well we need these vultures.
Well you know what the problem is now they,
they are,
they have laws in this part of a Europe where you have to kill livestock when
they die,
you have to burn them.
So because of that,
the vultures don't get tiff naturally play at prey off the livestock.
So vultures are actually going down and attacking live things cause they're
starving to death because the government cleans up the dead animals and burns
them and doesn't allow the vultures to eat them.
So now you have vultures that are caring way dogs and they're going after pets.
They're getting livestock and shit.
It's like teachers are scary.
Flowcharts are scary.
That's,
you know,
as much as the oh sweet,
cool.
That nature.
Well yeah.
To what point [inaudible] nature is nice and cool.
As long as you're in your car when you're in your house or you have a gun,
right.
Or there's,
you know,
slow people behind you and in front of you,
that will get eaten first.
Exactly.
I had a dream last night that a friend of mine,
um,
have like a,
an animal snuck into his house and we couldn't get it out and it wasn't a big
animal.
It's like a raccoon or something.
But it was terrifying in this dream.
You know,
like the raccoon was behind the TV and we're trying to chase it out.
What sticks and it's like making it like fuck shit.
You know,
like think about how little the goddamn raccoon isn't that terrified of this
fucker,
you know,
get them out of your house man.
You know,
we're trying to stick,
stick a fucking broom stick back there to get rid of the raccoons.
And in my dream it was horrific.
It was,
cause I was thinking if this raccoon just goes for it right.
And just jumps on my face,
I am fucked.
My face has made it a toilet paper.
It's a like soft,
mushy shit.
Right.
You know,
your you face is barely more durable than a flashlight.
Yup.
As it could have.
Raccoons and skunks both scare me because in my backyard,
yeah.
Somehow they get in there once in a while and have like a fenced in yard.
Do you leave cat food out there?
No.
No,
but somehow they just do it.
Like there's,
it's weird and I'll just be sitting outside,
you know,
whatever on the porch and out of nowhere I'll just see like the skunk or a
raccoon like running towards me cause it's like,
it doesn't realize that I'm sitting there and I'd be like,
Hey,
get away from here.
And they said it just stops.
I'm like,
okay.
Hopefully it just turns around and walks away and nothing happened.
Most of the times they won't engage you unless they're rabid.
Right,
right.
But they will engage you if they're rabid.
Yup.
Yeah.
You know,
there's that tours that you're really fucked if you get bitten and you've got,
if you get rabies,
you get bit by some with rabies,
you got to get like 10 gigantic needles and their
stomach.
Right.
It doesn't go around your stomach.
Oh,
fucking Christ.
And they're huge needles.
Yeah.
It's apparently like really bad to get rabies.
I got beat by a dog whines and uh,
you know,
they worked at,
to me the doctor was like,
yeah,
we're not going to give you a shit because of the take your chances.
He's better than taking a rabies shot.
You don't want to ever,
unless you're really convinced that you have rabies,
you don't want to take it and be on bed.
Yeah.
I guess there's a lot of bats here in Los Angeles.
Then being found with rabies,
payback,
fucking Christ,
Bam,
Bam.
I'm wearing a back country tee shirts on.
Hey Dude,
who gave me this New Jersey.
Thank you very much.
Some fellow hunter s Thompson fan country.
Yeah.
There's a great story about these guys from Harvard who went to Africa to study
these bats that migrate out of this cave and they sat in the front of the cave
and every night at a certain time when you know it became dusk,
these bats would fly out and mass is this massive number of bats.
This is an enormous cave and they would be like millions and millions of bats.
Well these guys,
they sat down in front of this like film and record things,
whatever the fuck they're going to do scientifically.
And what they didn't anticipate is the assault of bat shit that hit them as they
came out of this cage.
They just shit all at once.
So they were literally in the firing path of a wave of shit.
A hundred miles high.
Millions of bats shitting on their face.
Okay.
So they get back to uh,
to America and they're horribly ill bleeding from their eyes.
There are deadly sick and they die.
They both died.
Both died.
Yeah.
It's insanely toxic.
They just got toxic levels of nitrogen and bat shit and it goes in your eyes and
it's in your face and your skin is good.
It's in going through your fucking skin when it's toxic shit
took about,
fuck man,
I took about it.
Stories like what happened to him,
what a,
you know,
a bunch of media on birds took a shit on him and that's why he died.
It's like,
yeah.
And he must've realized somewhere in the middle of that shit storm that probably
lasted an hour.
You know,
it was probably an hour of bats.
I mean,
there's,
this is insanely big cave apparently,
and there's just millions of bats there.
Bat Guano is,
uh,
I know they use it for shit.
I think they use it for fertilizer and stuff,
but only in the weeds.
Big Is it big powerful.
Daniela [inaudible] got the knowledge,
um,
that story that we talked about a couple of weeks ago about the couple that used
to be in the CIA.
Uh,
and they had a retired and we're making plants in their basement.
They were growing tomatoes and stuff like that.
And the fucking DEA kicks down their door,
guns blazing rifles in their face and finds their tomatoes and the basement boy,
oh boy.
Is that a silly goddamn storage.
What turns out these,
uh,
people,
um,
the reason
why the CIA did this or the DEA did this is they,
uh,
followed their car.
Their car had been parked at a hydroponic store and they took a photo of the
car,
the license plate.
They ran the plates.
And that's how they find where the houses are,
where people are growing.
That's this genius fucking group of ASP fucks called the DEA that think that
everyone growing anything indoors.
My sister's ex husband used to grow tomatoes and shit cause they lived in
Boston.
They had a full set up in the basement.
Right,
and even smoke weed.
Right.
We had a full set up,
but that guy would be like under suspicion.
Of course if you,
if they,
they're allowed to pass by your fucking house.
This is how stupid this such as this situation is.
All they're doing is growing plants.
By the way,
I might add,
but not making math.
Okay.
Right.
The,
they're allowed to go by the places where they teach you how to grow plants.
Take pictures of your fucking license plate and then run them on the suspicion
of you doing drugs.
Find out what the fuck you live.
Stake out your house.
Yup.
For sure.
They're growing plants.
We're going in boys go in guns blazing with dogs and shoot your dog.
If you've got one,
they shoot your fucking dog.
Almost every time they go into these people's houses,
they shoot puppies,
they'll shoot collies.
They don't care if your dog is a threat,
they shoot dogs and then they find out you're making tomatoes.
I mean that's the dumbest shit.
That's why to meet piece me off when I or people who are like,
I love the freedom but I'm pro drug war.
I'm against legal prostitution and I'm against,
it's like [inaudible] motherfucker.
You're only put the freedom of the stuff you like.
That's just,
well Obama said recently you had a um,
a speech in Mexico.
He said that he didn't think that making marijuana legal was a good idea.
So the muscle Arius thing ever like the idea that making anything that EI
benefits people [inaudible] people want to do and see there's no victims,
right.
To say that.
And then you're talking specifically with the people who would,
in a logical scenario benefit from being legal.
The reason why all this money is being made by drug cartels is because drugs are
illegal,
right?
If drugs were legal,
these people wouldn't be making that money.
I would have a business.
I mean,
just that alone is impossible for some people to grasp.
And I mean,
even when people that are against each fetal is off,
it could it because they are control freaks who want to some morality for us
according to their standards of morality to and everyone else.
Even those guys still look at the evidence.
Eastbourne be fun working in terms of keeping dry the rates of addiction in
order use low.
It's not,
so what the fuck are you doing it?
She's like taking a bunch of money,
putting it in the toilet and flushing because if you are not affecting demand or
supply,
why the fuck are you doing it?
Yeah.
The best example that we have about whether or not it's good to legalize drugs
as Portugal.
Yeah,
I have to do with it.
And they have lowered their rates of addiction,
lowered the rates of crime.
It's,
it's real simple folks.
People don't like being told what to do and they're going to do whatever the
fuck they want to do.
But if you tell him what to do,
then they're going to rebel.
And that's just what they do.
And when people rebel,
sometimes they're not even doing what they want to do.
They're just doing what you don't want them to do.
So that seems like the thing to do because they don't like you fucking
controlling them.
You know?
When I moved here from Italy,
I didn't know about the age 21 thing about drinking.
I thought you're going to say about banging chicks.
There's a like easily,
I don't even think he died.
Maybe it doesn't have an age limit.
If he does nobody on force it.
So if you are eight year old,
you go to the store to buy for your mom a bottle of wine.
Nobody asks anything.
But because it's the kind of shit that your grandparents have for lunch,
it's not glamorous.
It's not like,
cool,
I got booze.
I'm going to start down and get like crazy when I still a year people who would
start drinking as teenagers as a,
but it'll keep me that exciting thing they would down.
I'll go like crazy,
throw up all over themselves.
I'm like,
Hey,
that's fucking disgusting.
Why would you do that to yourselves?
You know?
It's like,
yeah,
you know,
you'll learn how to drink a little bit at a time.
And to me it's like you learn how to drink as a kid.
You learn how to drink with your grandparents,
where he's like,
if you have a seat,
you feel happy and stuff.
If you have more than a,
see if you've got a headache kind of one day you do,
and you're like,
oh fuck,
you're right,
I got a headache.
And it's kind of weird that this is the most successful society ever,
because it really is,
right.
If you had to look at it as far as like the what,
what's been done by this society,
American society,
maybe that's the only way you can really get shit done.
Maybe you have to have this fucking weird button down,
repressed in order to work that kind of hours.
And people were willing to work.
Whereas in Italy they'd take like,
what,
two hours a day off just to take a shit.
And nobody does that.
Have a shoot the brick,
you know,
he's an awesome place to retiring,
but to get anything done.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Well,
I know marvelous Marvin Hagler did it.
Yup.
Marvin Hagler when he retired from being,
you know the fucking man.
Yup.
Uh,
was one of the best boxers ever.
Went to Italy and just said,
fuck it.
I'm just chilling here forever.
It can be come up Italian movie star and he lives in my town.
A friend of mine told me that you're answering to it and at the GMO,
the time and their various,
he's a weird,
he's the weirdest case ever for a boxer because he still has his wins.
Yeah,
he was.
And Man,
what a good boxer.
He was amazing.
He was one of the all time greats,
but he's still like,
he's lucid when he talks and he lost to sugar ray Leonard and he said,
that's it.
I'm done.
Right.
And,
but he really meant it.
He's the only guy that I can ever recall.
Nope.
Everybody out.
Like sugar ray Leonard broke everybody's heart.
He came back,
right.
One,
a couple of fights and then lost a couple of fights.
Very bad.
Right.
The Terry Norris fight.
Classic example.
That was a brutal beat down.
Yeah.
Terry Noyes beat the shit out of them.
That was scary.
The,
um,
the,
the fight with Hector Camacho and Hector Camacho stopped him and was like,
oh Jesus.
You know,
he was at the end.
He broke everybody's heart just like everybody else.
Right.
It's no,
I,
there was martyred man.
He made the call.
He didn't really take that much abuse actually.
He actually took more up using some of the fights he wall like there was the
fight with Mugabi.
Yeah.
Where they beat the shit out of each other or even the one with Tom he earns
that was like the most intense around have ever seen in combat sports.
Yeah.
You want to watch a great fight there from Hagler Hearns on Youtube.
Somebody put it up on a end.
Rick Soundtrack.
They have like Voodoo child going on.
The Marvin Hagler highlight is like the coolest thing ever.
Yeah,
I tweeted that a while back.
That's an amazing highlight.
Yeah.
He was a beast man.
He was a,
when I was a kid he was a big inspiration for me.
I was living in Boston cause I remember he was supposed to fight Mustapha Ham
show and they had some TV special that was following him,
training in the,
and he would go to the Cape in the winter time whereas nobody in the Cape,
it's horrible bowl,
right for reasoning,
you know,
many,
many degrees below zero windchill factor.
Wind coming off the wall or ripping your fucking skin apart and he's out there
running,
screaming war.
She would just scream war as he was running up sand dunes and shit.
Fuck if he's the phone and you just look at Devita,
they're like,
yeah,
no thanks.
He beat the fuck out of some people,
man.
Even higher.
It was a beast.
Yeah.
If you look at the Mugabi fight is a great example of that.
He just,
you couldn't hurt him.
He had a chin like nobody,
he had like they've,
they did like this weird thing with them with a,
um,
they scanned his head and they found out that his mandible muscles,
the muscles on the sides of his head were like much larger than a normal
persons.
And they were like,
literally the man has like builtin headgear and you're like,
wait,
I guess he get that from biting down maybe or something.
Or biting down on mouthpieces or what if it could be genetics?
Well,
whatever it was,
the dude was just like really hard to hurt and that was one of the big things
about him.
Like you could never hurt.
Like Tommy Hearns couldn't hurt them.
It Gabi couldn't hurt him.
They would nail it,
but he would just keep coming forward.
Nobody ever stopped Marvin Hagler.
Nobody ever stopped Marvin Hagler no,
not even close.
Nobody even fucking came close to stop in that guy.
Yeah.
There's been a few guys like that throughout history that just for whatever
reason,
just had that extra motivation above and beyond everyone else.
And he was Marco call it quits when he did.
Because I mean you do see those guys a,
I know gay or I left these ungodly chains who can take Sam be it was,
but after a while,
you know you hit the spot to where he's like okay you'll clock the x amount of
mantras you could take in your life is done.
Yeah.
Now every other funds you take is going to throw up you.
That's,
that's gets really sad to see old great fighters that don't,
that's what the saddest aspects of fighting and what,
it'd be amazing if they figured out how to fix that with like stem cell
research.
Like to figure it out.
How to reverse pugilistic dementia and cure brain damage from fighting.
That would be beautiful.
Yeah.
Cause it makes it seem twice about training.
Stand up sparring for real because you know,
you'll get out board.
It's all the themes,
right.
And socks.
But he's gotten bad concussions from grappling fall funding,
you know,
and a lot of,
a lot
of heads collide with knees and accidental things happen where you get knocked
unconscious.
You're taking a chance to matter what you do.
But it's the subconcussive blows from boxing.
The continual process of getting hit.
Yeah cause that's not an accident in training.
That's the name of the game.
He's continuing to head and you'd take it over and over and over after a while,
you know they're all,
there's can be a good thing for your brain.
Especially if you're training with some fucking animal who hits hard.
If you're in there with like some guy on a regular basis and he likes to beat up
sparring partners.
Great.
You just got a little stupid or every day.
Exactly every day in your life.
Get a little stupider.
How would he do,
he was like when you aspire,
because when you get apple is easy,
you know as long as you are not a daycare,
not going to hurt people.
Why these accidents happen but just fine.
Really good training partners.
Right.
What's the most important thing?
Cause,
I mean don't you find some time when you are done with the spring session in STI
keen that sometimes you are not entirely sure how well you did cause he's like,
you didn't really go full out where you like that shot that I hate him weights.
Was it sim?
What?
Did he have the juice really behind it?
Told her he would have just shrugged it off and that's it.
You know,
it's like does it ever happen to you or do you feel like you know what's up by
the end?
Uh,
well I think you have to like ego wise,
you have to realize that like when you,
when you're sparring,
you're both pulling back.
So shots that you got hit with you maybe would've got hurt in a,
in a real situation and shots that you got hit with your response,
maybe you wouldn't have been able to even deliver it.
So it can get unrealistic for guys who liked to spar light,
but they take shots on the Chin and then keep moving forward as if in real life
they would be okay.
Right.
Because that becomes a real problem for sure.
Right?
And that's one of the problems with developing techniques under minimal stress.
But if you're doing it correctly,
if you're being well trained,
they want to allow you to develop is really bad habits because those really bad
habits like you can,
you can,
you can fundamentally alter the thinking that allows you to spar like that.
Right.
Number one most important thing.
It's two important things,
but number one is great trainers.
You have to have a trainer that trains you in a technical way and she makes the
class move in a tactical way as well.
And number two train partners that you could trust so you're not going to blast
each other.
Yeah.
And then you've got to make sure that you,
you go full out on the myths and the bag,
right.
So that in a real scenario you can deliver those shots with full impact.
You know,
but it's,
it's a tricky game.
Striking is a tricky game.
You know,
it's a,
it's a very,
very dangerous endeavor,
but it's awesome to get good at.
Ou
feels good.
I everybody's deadline,
right?
If you'd do a little too two tell Israeli state cause it's like,
come on,
we are barely touching each other.
If you go a little too hard,
it does a role.
Brain cells saying goodbye.
Yeah.
My young days when I was a young man,
one of the things that I was concerned most with was the potential of brain
damage.
Yeah.
You know I,
I've known too many people that I'd seen slowly slip away from the gym wars and
kickboxing and boxing training and stuff like that.
But you know,
on the hand it's fucking exciting to watch than if people are going to keep
doing it.
Like the,
did you see a,
the Mayweather fight this weekend and I may wear the red.
Just kind of take it to the why.
Why is that?
It's fucking brilliant.
Brilliant,
brilliant.
Beautiful.
To Watch.
If I was fighting at this level,
I'll probably do the same thing.
He's like,
I'm not going to get hurt.
I'm going to get paid a shitload of money.
I win white the fuck should I take chances?
So he took chances.
He does.
You know,
in this fight is on a very different kind of fight.
He stood right in front of this dude.
Robert Guerrero was a tough guy,
but he,
he out toughed him.
He out moved him,
he out angled them.
He clinically clenched ahold of them and didn't let them like manipulate him and
bullying him and rip shots on him,
and then he'd just counter punch to the fucking shit out of him.
Man.
It just,
it was brilliant.
I mean,
it wasn't the most exciting fighter in the world,
but as someone who appreciates technique,
I appreciate the shit out how he did it.
He says,
just an awesome boxer.
Right?
It talks crazy,
mad shit.
But that's also why people buy is paper.
Of course.
I don't know the dude.
You know me.
I know the dude's a bad motherfucker though,
right?
Yeah.
As far as when it comes to boxing.
He's made some crazy claims about MMA,
which I always find hilarious,
but I don't fault him for that because he's in the business of promoting.
Yeah.
You know,
that's like part of his shtick is,
look,
he knows there's a lot of people that are paying attention to MMA.
If he starts talking mad shit about MMA fighters,
people who don't even watch boxing will pay attention to his fight and even to
buy it,
to see him lose.
Like I saw some people that I know there were like tweeting,
you know,
I think maybe where they're loses this weekend.
I was like,
what are you even saying?
What are you even talking about?
Do you know what you're watching when you're watching that guy?
You're watching the all time hall of Famer and Robert Career was a good fighter.
He's a very good Friday.
It'd be an interesting fight,
but they were just going to box his fucking face off.
That's what he's gonna do.
Cause he's one of the best ever.
I made 80 bucks on him,
so I was pleased to check what was the odds.
They got really bad.
So I took back to lot,
but I was so sure that it was like,
cause like there's no way in hell kick.
It's got a Louis.
It just,
it hurt his hand.
That's the only way he can,
and he did it.
In fact,
he hurt his right hand somehow in the fight,
but he kept throwing it or the John Johnson,
you know,
goes Gus was going to win.
But he's like,
well shit can happen.
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
act of God type Shit.
You know,
he,
John John's foot wasn't even broken that toe wasn't even Brooklyn.
Just dislocated it and twisted it and broke the skin.
You crazy.
Yeah.
But that wasn't even broken.
And there's like,
he'll be back training at six weeks.
Like what?
Six fucking weeks?
That looked like a six month injury,
but apparently,
nope,
no problem.
They,
as soon as they said it,
they,
they stitched it up,
the uh,
the cut set it and they're like,
you'd be all right.
Yes.
Funny how he barely even,
I don't think you noticed the,
until the wheels.
Yeah.
Who's doing cartwheels?
We're fucked up toe.
And you were like,
Hey,
look at your food.
No,
no,
no.
He noticed it.
Oh,
he not?
Yeah.
We were talking and he was like standing like he,
I think he noticed that when he's stepping and who's stepping in something wet,
so he looked down,
I realized it was blood.
It's like,
where's this blood?
Oh my goodness.
I have a broken toe.
That's when he realized there was something wrong.
Right.
It was totally him.
Him looking down at it.
Yeah.
It was fucking crazy.
It was a crazy moment because nobody knew what to do because I was interviewing
him and it was all antique,
so nobody acted,
so I had to kind of like grabbed the stool,
calling the doctor,
sit down and you still want to do this.
It's like,
I just want to talk.
I'm like,
okay.
It was a weird moment.
I know you have to tell somebody to get a chair for him.
Well,
I got a chair for him.
I wound up getting the chair myself.
I was like,
can we get him a chair?
And then I'm like,
no one's moving.
Right.
Like everybody was like,
Oh shit.
You know?
No one wanted to get in the way on TV either.
It's one of those things you're probably,
it's probably like strict rules as to who can enter the octagon and that
situation,
you know,
you have.
Right.
But that,
that was probably one of the weirdest injuries that I've ever seen.
Where,
who,
who saw that comment?
Some guy up,
you hurt your own self and yeah,
you are this close to losing the fight.
When you have dominated the,
he would've lost,
they would have taped that fucking foot together would have gone if they could,
if they,
even if he didn't have to tape it together,
chair would have had to come close enough to clinch him and he'd beat you up so
bad on that first round chair was in a lot of trouble doing anything in that
second round.
Yeah.
I mean,
the fight was almost over.
The round was almost over.
I think there was like 30 seconds to go,
maybe less.
But beating that he put on shale was ferocious.
Man.
Those elbows,
he's a motherfucker,
man.
He's a motherfucker and he's getting better all the time.
It's so cool to watch.
Uh,
what is like a real exceptional athlete as exceptionally gifted person come
along in MMA.
Yup.
You know,
cause he to me is like a Roy Jones Jr type character.
Like a guy who's coming out of nowhere who's just so athletically talented as
well as all the other things as well as disciplined as well as he's got it.
He's got the whole package and he's creative.
He's fun to watch.
It's just not going to do address the same fucking thing that he does well.
And he wins by whatever.
He actually pulled self these crazy moves that you never know what he's going to
do.
And it's like that's spinning elbow.
He does when he gets you up against the cage,
it's like a tornado of bones.
It's,
it's
just getting smashed that just,
and you know,
it's amazing.
The kids are only like 25 like what the fuck?
What,
how,
what's it gonna be like?
And he's 35.
Yeah.
Cause he's not really taking damage.
So these are 80 can go on forever.
Yeah.
How's it going to take damage?
She was like,
who is going to be able to solve that fucking puzzle?
Like what?
What is,
you know,
sometimes you look at a guy's style and it's like,
hmm.
You know what that Guy Needs?
If you find a guy who does this and that he might be in trouble.
The closest is if Vito Belfort catched him in an arm bar.
Yeah.
But I mean that's sure everybody comes into was one mistake happens.
Anybody couldn't.
There's always that percentage where you'll Kennedy was any fight no matter
what.
But he's like,
the outs are so low.
Right.
And you know what,
what,
what freaks me out about that arm bar?
He left that to fuck his hormone.
Yeah.
He left that dude way hyper extend his arm and he never tapped.
Nope.
He did not tap.
And then he'd beat him up and then he tapped him.
He tapped him with the fuck dot bomb.
It's like,
so he's got this mental game down as well?
Yeah.
Cause it's like he got the siren puppy in the first round and then he wasn't
watching the fort.
So he's like,
he's not even like,
he walked right away and Dan,
he was like,
could pay
attention to this nasty armbar to veto or did that,
that was some real black belts.
Shit.
Perfect.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
oof.
Most guys would have tapped.
I would have tapped like,
how do you feel if you are a bad for it,
you pull it off the perfect move.
Papa disarm.
You got to Ronda Rousey.
I bitch,
you got to Ronda Rousey.
Ronda breaks arms.
She doesn't wait for you to tap.
Yup.
She's not even trying to get you to taps is trying to break your shit.
Her mentality is not the ta.
You'll tap and then when her mentality is break it right and then they got a
tap,
then the game's over.
Yup.
Yeah.
That's what,
what a crazy way to make 11 he says,
so your podcast,
you call your podcasts drunk and doused.
Yup.
You,
you're fairly sober
sometimes.
Why do you call it drunk in Dallas?
I like wine and I liked that.
Always.
No,
I guess,
I mean to me it's like a,
there's always things like Kung Fu movies or something to figure off the old
dude who looks like all drunk and stuff and he can fix it off these amazing
seeing.
It's like how the fuck did that happen?
I dig the idea of figuring out our ways,
whether it's applied to martial arts,
we were up light to life to nobody can figure out how you did it,
but you pull it off.
Right.
And to not think along the same lines like everybody else is going through the
plan.
There's an obvious eight,
two B,
B two C to get the results,
but to have an alternate way to get shit done.
I like it.
So that's why he came up with drunken Dallas again.
That's the high mind.
That verse from the low minded version is I liked that way.
He's a man.
I like wine.
Did you draw this,
this picture that's on your tee shirt?
No.
I ask,
uh,
I ask a desired taste.
I told her what I wanted and she worked with me a little.
She was really cool.
She was also so what is it is a dude punching a guy who's getting kissed?
Yeah.
There's this guy who was making out with this heart Shipley woman while he's
making out with their chair you sporting wine over the two of them as they're
another guy punches him and other guys punching him while he's leaning backward,
kissing the woman.
He managed to use a leg to kick him in the balls so it's like that is one of the
worst shirts have ever seen in my life and you need to burn it and never wear it
again and you need a question.
Your sanity for mass producing these fucking things.
You love it.
I love it.
It's so multidimensional.
Yeah,
it's a,
I'm a lover and the fight,
it's a very strange shirt dude.
You sending a really confusing message and you're also a cartoonist or you
should have like a drunk in Dallas Adventures.
This guy just running around drinking and making out with chicks and kicking
random bullies in the balls.
That's not a bad plan.
You've only been in America short amount of time folks.
We need to,
we need a season him.
We needed to get Danieli Bolelli just accustomed to our way of life or this is
ridiculous and we don't allow you to the other interpretation people,
they're like,
no but wait this dude duties punching game and he's leaning back.
I'm like well in that case,
if he's still managed to Macau with a woman and drink after getting patch,
I dig it.
That message too.
I would think he really needs to stop being cocky and let go of the girl and
deal with dude is trying to kick his ass.
Cause this is silly.
I've,
I was your coach.
I'll be very mad at you.
Not really a,
you got to address the situation.
Um,
what do you,
uh,
how often are you doing your podcast?
I do twice a month.
They do once a month with a guest and then once a month is like random rants and
chat with my friends or each and Devon were helping me put together.
You do it out of your house?
No,
we recorded,
well actually we started doing a few at my house.
We were doing it in a studio first and then now we,
um,
we decided to move the ball,
the studios for a few times.
We did it in my house was cool.
Yeah.
It's cool to be able to do it wherever the fuck you want it.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's cool to have a central location,
but I,
I like when,
uh,
sometimes when people do like already does a lot of them on the road and just
starts,
uh,
you know,
brings,
it,
brings microphone sets up and that way if he's in weird places,
he can get strange people.
Right.
It's gone or he's gone.
I moved to New York City.
It did,
cause he's a silly bitch and he's all Jude out I think.
So you can go to the motherland,
you can't go to Israel.
So he thinks he's just going to go to New York and that's the other junior
motherland.
They're going to accept him with open open sandwiches.
We had a going away podcast where he brought this huge box and inside the box
it's just shit that he was going to throw away.
And he's like,
you know,
if you come to the show or may get give away presents the whole night.
He had like all this random shit that he like bought when he was really stoned
and never used or never even opened the boxes.
It's like,
you know,
random things like raid air bombs,
for cockroaches and like just weird shit.
And then at one point he's like,
all right,
who here?
You know,
the next five people who here does drugs,
you know,
raise your hand.
And he's just throwing out prescription medicine to people.
It's fucking like,
he grabs this one thing,
he goes,
oh,
he better not do that.
Like,
cause I think it was like acid or something.
He just puts it in his pocket.
But it was just ridiculous.
And then he hands up,
he opens like this thing of joints and he gives a joint to every single person
in the audience.
And then he's like,
people in the audience probably like 30 40 something like that and get 40 joints
way.
So yeah.
Oh yeah.
He gave a lie.
I mean it was just a huge thing of joints.
And,
and he's just like [inaudible] over boaters,
smoker and so we s everyone's smoking it and just in the comedy so you can't
even see anything.
And then there's like this Boston uh,
you know thing going on downstairs for like all the,
like a tribute or a,
a marathon,
a show where they're making the raising money for charity show.
There's this charity show going on and you just sing the smoke just gushing down
that back hallway like going into that was in the main room,
which is right below,
right below the La early room.
That's
hilarious.
So funny though.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
You mean literally burned his bridge?
Exactly.
Yeah.
You can't do that indoors.
He,
they can lose their license for that show and that's supposed to do that.
You fuck allegedly that all happened.
Yeah,
allegedly because the people were smoking in the audience.
I think you used to be able to smoke on stage a part of an ass.
Our
artistic performance.
You can still do that.
I still do that because Stan hope used to do it.
He's just smoke on stage and make fun of how it was a part of artistic
performance.
You're allowed to smoke on stage.
Some stupid loophole.
Yup.
I remember that.
He,
cause he smoked a in Ohio,
he went and played this like a building that's owned by the campus.
It's just like a building for speech and you know speakers and stuff like that.
But it had a bar in it.
It was really weird and I think they tore it down since then.
Ohio state and Doug played and he wanted to smoke so bad but this is like owned
by the school and there's like definitely no smoking allowed in it.
And he goes,
well I don't care,
everyone can smoke.
And he just starts looking like the bartender lady who was just like this older
lady that,
you know,
it probably was a retired and you just,
I work at the old college but she was like,
Oh stop it please.
And she was just kidding up sex.
He didn't have to do.
And the whole campus was just like cigarettes.
Everyone was smoking cigarettes on ignite.
Little in that little room.
And I leaned over and helped did it on stage.
So when they allowed,
just tell him to stop
doing onstage there.
Was it a,
an artistic performance thing?
I don't know.
He did it anyway.
He just didn't care.
It's what everyone in the audience to do it.
Awesome
problem with six cigarettes is it fucks with other people.
You know,
that's the problem with that stinky drug and it doesn't,
that's the one thing that Stan hope says that if he could stop,
he did this opening Anthony thing recently where they were talking about
addiction because you know,
Jim Norton is like real clean and um,
and it made some news source.
It was,
cause it was an interesting conversation.
We're standing up was advocating that,
you know,
he's a shitty comic if he's not drunk and uh,
that's why he stays drunk and that comics like Mitch Hedberg,
the only way you would have gotten those guys with the drugs,
hunter s Thompson,
the only way you would've got him as with the drugs and the alcohol,
that's how you create something like that.
You know,
it's just a,
you know,
a weird sort of conversation to get into with people.
But he said the one thing that he regrets is the cigarettes.
Yeah.
He said it doesn't give you any benefit in these completely hooked on him.
Right.
But they say that does give you a benefit,
like synapsis,
like Stephen King claims that when he stopped smoking,
then he noticed a difference in his ability to fire that.
Like his mind fired slower.
These was just the right after he stopped or like why?
I don't know.
He just,
he made a comment on it.
I don't think it's right after.
I think it's the effect of it,
I think.
I think when people are on nicotine all the time,
nicotine is like some kind of a stimulant.
Yeah.
It relaxes.
I tell you,
it wasn't really relaxed.
That's sort of sort of a,
Oh,
it does.
It relaxes your nerves and everything.
But the reason why it relaxes it because it feeds your addiction.
That's that overlap.
Yeah.
That's absolutely.
No,
no,
no.
That's what you,
when you get an addiction and you become a junkie,
you need it.
You need it,
God Damn,
I'm stressed out of it and you didn't even need it.
Got It.
Well,
cigarettes relax me,
but they also got you to the point where you needed them where you were fucking
crazy and he looks,
it's like,
but it is a stimulant meaning,
but that's not a relaxing,
it's the exact opposite of something that relaxes you.
It's stimulant is the opposite of something that relaxes.
Right?
Exactly.
That's why when you,
you're,
you definitely do get that feeling of relaxation,
but that feeling of relaxation is the same thing that heroin users get when they
shoot up.
Right?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And they see those little white glowing butterflies float out of their soul.
I said laid back on the pillow and let go of the rubber band.
That's that hot heroin.
Just race through your body.
Thank you.
Jessica was about 17 people at least any right now to fall back into heroin.
The people
done it,
man.
That's the problem with heroin.
Thanks.
Say it's fucking awesome.
Yup.
People that have even take those pills.
I've said it's awesome.
Oxycontin,
oxycontin issues.
Yeah.
Some,
some guy posted a thread about it on a message board is talking about opiates,
how amazing they are.
It's just terrible that they're so bad for you that you can't carry a gun.
But the feeling apparently is just amazing.
I read somebody a awhile ago say now,
yeah it's fucked up cause he mess you up or randos limits.
So we should leave it legal for people who have like a few months left to live
cause he's like,
what are they going to fuck up anyway?
You know,
you're dying anyway,
but you feel like a god for the last three months.
And uh,
I agree with that.
Well that's what we're doing anyway.
When we give him morphine,
that's what we're doing.
When we given them oxycontin's we're,
we're basically giving them opiates.
Right.
Mark Finney's is weird.
I mean when you think about that whole thing is like,
oh yeah.
Speaking of freedoms,
it's like people throw freedom except that you can't kill yourself the way you
want to.
You know,
she,
her dying is a little painful disease.
You need to die slowly and painfully because otherwise,
because otherwise are called angry.
Exactly.
It's like life is not,
you'll stay or leave,
but,
but then we have the hall space,
which he really,
I mean euthanasia is not legal so you can't really do it,
but we'll just give you a morphine for calm for wait,
you said do you need a mortar?
Marfino okay,
we'll give you a [inaudible].
You said you're still in pain,
you know,
of course you just got to keep shooting up until he dies,
but rather than doing it tonight,
you main cool the way.
Where did you shoot happen?
They are done in 50 minutes like you do with a dog.
You do it over a period of days or a week or something.
Just compare grandma to a dog.
So much goddamn crazy Italians.
But as thing is like people that are all a piece about,
ah,
it's terrible.
He's like,
well you don't fucking do it about that.
You would die the way you want to.
How about you let other people die is that someone can get it and then give it
to you.
That's the worry.
The worry about having shit that could fuck you up.
Obviously people doing it to people against their will or,
yeah,
that's of course,
but then that's what you work on,
on like anything that you don't do,
you know you're done.
[inaudible] Samsung just because it can be used against their wheel.
You work on the fact on those cases when it's used against somebody Swale,
which is the argument for not worrying about how many guns are out there but
worrying about the mental health of a nation and allows a certain percentage of
people go on gun fueled rampages right,
but who are those people?
Why are they doing
it?
Exactly.
But nobody concentrates on that.
They concentrate on the guns.
There's too many guns.
Right.
It's like,
no,
that's exactly,
that's me.
Seemed to point cause it's about,
it boils down to in your hand or well I don't know about y'all butts in
somebodies hand having a fucking atomic weapon.
It wouldn't be a problem because you're not nuts and they are not going to use
it.
Cause I would be a problem with it.
But,
uh,
but you know what I mean is like the worst thing and it really boils down to
individual to individual.
It's not the same thing.
The problem can seem because it's who's going to decide who's the same
individual and which one isn't.
You know,
the states we had that always works really well,
but then if you don't do it,
that means every cycle in the world can get easily their hands on some messed up
stuff if you do the way it is clearly an imperfect system because he's done
through the state where they're always enormous loophole sinks that doesn't
work,
isn't it a feature.
And so he's three.
I can see why people argue passionately both ways because you can see there's a
lot,
there's kind of a logic both ways in that yeah,
there's definitely a logic both ways.
I mean the idea that people are smart enough to figure out what to do and not to
do,
it's been proven false time and time again.
Yup.
People are stupid shit load of us.
They're stupid as fuck.
But then the argument is the reason why they're stupid as fuck.
Cause that we allow him to survive or being stupid and don't allow these dumb
mistakes to happen.
They die off.
We're just so attached to every single precious life that we're not allowed,
allowing stupid people that die from being stupid.
So stupidity is no longer a negative like factor.
Right.
And in evolution you're allowed to be stupid and live Super Fox.
That's fucking scary.
At the same time,
if it's fucking stupid.
So
it says [inaudible] is low from that too.
Like,
well,
go do eugenics program where we just set up something good.
It's,
you can't do that either.
Yeah.
That's a problem where there's no way to do it.
Right.
There's no way we're just,
we're stuck in the middle or just the,
we're on a stage of developing and one day we'll be way better than this,
but right now it's Kinda fucked.
Wait back there to me.
What the fuck?
It's possible.
Even better than the god that is Daniela [inaudible] Jesus philosophy.
The future is going to be amazing.
We'll have even better God's wow.
Um,
I don't know if I couldn't deal with that.
Are you still teaching?
Yeah.
Where are you teaching that?
I'm teaching a few courses across the long beach.
A few courses give you a hard time for your controversial viewpoints.
They decide these easier to just not deal with it because if they come after
you,
then you can open a show shit storm of why are you firing?
Gave him a note of that and you know what,
whatever,
it doesn't matter anyway because we'll do things the way we want anyway.
Say whatever the fuck you want going into class to them.
Does anybody ever take umbrage with some of the things that you say?
Sure.
They do not,
not face to face.
Nobody says anything.
Well that's kind of cool.
Yeah.
So you teach all this crazy shit your classes and everybody's like,
well it's fucking historically accurate.
Yeah,
I mean it's not,
um,
it's like,
sure,
I would do it to me about the specific event because I don't in the class,
I don't really try to sell a viewpoint.
So I'll say something really radical,
but I'll also show all the exception to what I just said.
Right.
So it doesn't sound like I'm trying to sell you something because the reason why
I asked you is because you,
you went on like some Twitter rampage awhile back,
but post based.
Yeah.
That was what you wrote like a whole essay about education system.
They had an open letter to academia that closes with the immortal words of
Tupac.
Fuck you and your motherfucking Mama.
So yes,
that I'm sure
that's how you make it count.
You got to speak their language.
Yeah.
Well man,
listen,
I wish I had a fucking teacher.
Like I had dom Irrera.
It used to be a teacher.
I wish he was one of my teachers and I wish you were one of my teachers too.
That would have been an amazing time when school.
Instead I got caught with a bunch of people that made teaching or made school
boring as fuck.
That's the majority.
I didn't know that history was interesting until I listen to Dan Carlin.
Yeah,
but that's what I mean.
That's what drives me insane.
A guy like Dan Carlin was fucking amazing in case we haven't made that clear
already.
He is not a historian and that's why he's fucking amazing cause mostly story
hands.
By the time they got through their phd,
all the creativity,
all the juice has been squeezed out of them and there's nothing left because
there been made to conform to this really boring,
prudent care,
full way of telling stories where they can say a sentence without 17 exceptions
to what they say and you have.
He didn't see it on paragraph 17 and he's like,
nobody wants to listen to it.
It's fucking boring down.
Carolyn goes on,
put on a historical podcast.
Then becomes something that people around the ward one at least into because
he's a storyteller because it makes it exciting.
Being boring is a fucking real curse.
Telling them about it.
It's almost like there's something wrong with you if you're born.
It's almost like you can't figure out a better way to express this information,
this information that you're giving,
you're giving it an a really fucking shitty way.
Yup.
You need to work on your presentation son and that's the thing that eats some
way.
It sucks because you can tell to somebody,
look,
this sucks because it's so boring and it doesn't have the juice.
But the reality is that they,
I think they can all improve with 10% because it's not just a technique,
it's who you are.
Right.
These are people who are boring when they step where they are not teaching and
you're talking to them down the street.
It's just their personality that comes through.
It's like that Song Daniela [inaudible].
It takes every kind of people.
I could see Daniel Bell,
Ellie sitting around his house,
a little incense lit,
smoking a joint,
listened to some seventies Munich,
so maybe some Jim Croce Seventies Superman's cape,
no po,
no.
Seventh is more like my lowly side,
like Hendrix,
led Zeppelin kind of sets your shit.
Do Air Guitar around the House and your underwear.
I haven't for quite,
I'm sure I'm going to get to that level,
but I haven't quite got to that point yet.
If you do do it,
please make a youtube video so students know what the fuck they're dealing with.
Sign up for your course.
You probably are full glass.
Have you just played voodoo child and just just fully lipped all the lyric,
right.
Knew all of it and went around with it.
Yeah.
There's every other type now because through online you can find out a lot of
six a about people.
A bunch of students ask is like,
is that you windows picture where we are holding a key.
Then you have your middle finger out.
Just what's that about?
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
about that.
Yes.
I was rebellious.
It was before I realized the ultimate expression of rebellion is the drunk and
tower t-shirt.
Before then I was holding a baby giving the middle finger.
I said,
no,
I love my drunken tourists shit.
Tee Shirt got damn it and brother,
I'm sorry.
I talk shit about your tee shirt.
I had to,
I'm a comedian.
I got to do what I gotta do.
I've got to do what I got to do.
And how do they get your podcasts on iTunes?
I don't see us.
And if somebody wants to take your class,
can they take a class without signing up for anything else at the school?
Can you just pay to take your class?
Clearly not.
Yeah.
So how,
how has it,
how would someone make that happen?
Um,
Long Beach.
I'm actually not teaching a whole lot cause I'm there mainly I think I teach it
as to one class and the rest I do online,
which is sucks anyway cause as well.
In any case,
the um,
the main thing.
So I teach mostly at Santa Monica College live in person.
And uh,
it depends on the class.
You know,
some classes are the enrolled them to the limit,
other classes they enroll it and then they leave a bunch of empty chairs.
So
somebody might be able to just show up.
Talk to me.
No,
thank you for joining us,
my brother.
So the drunk and Dallas is available on iTunes.
You have a website for it?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
there,
there's a drunken tower is.com [inaudible] dot com and then there's just my own
website that's linked to that.
They're just,
my name
ended up,
that's it.
Pitches.
And if you look for him on Twitter,
it's D Bolelli,
B o l l e l I.
O l e l l y l one l.
First I tried to free ball it and I failed miserably.
Thank you to audible.com for sponsoring this podcast.
Go to audible.com forward slash Joe.
Get yourself a free audio book,
my friend's book.
We're also brought to you by stamps.com click on the microphone.
Use The code word J,
r e for a little special treat and an excellent deal on a great service and on
at.com that's o n n.
I t.
Used the code name Rogan and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Brian and I along with the lovely and talented Ari Shaffir.
We'll see you dirty bitches and Canada this weekend.
We will tomorrow night be at,
what's the name of the theater we're doing?
He doesn't know it's for motherfucker doesn't know.
I think it's called the vogue.
Yes.
The Vogue Theater in Vancouver tomorrow night for two shows.
So,
uh,
we can't wait and we're doing something different as time cause you fucking
people take too long with the God phones that
you don't know how to work the camera on.
So I'm going to take all the photos.
I'm gonna have someone take them with my camera.
So we'll get a perfect picture every time and then we'll upload it to the
website.
You can take it from there.
So it will also drive traffic to my website and don't go dude,
that's fucked up because I don't want to hear hints.
You bitches need to learn how to use your in 1967 fucking whack ass cell phone.
I'd have to wait for Dammit,
I shut it off by accident.
Hold on.
And there's a line of a thousand people taking pictures.
That's just ridiculous to the people that work at the theaters.
So they've requested I streamline the process.
So that is the only solution.
Alright,
your Fox.
So we love the Shit Outta Ya.
And uh,
we will see you on Monday.
Um,
and uh,
and that's around peace,
love,
happiness,
and uh,
good luck in your search for big foot.
We see you
friction.
Yeah.